I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everybody. Welcome to Office, ladies. Bonjour. Bonjour. I don't know. I don't know. I am wearing like this. This t-shirt is kind of like, it's like really soft and shimmery, but it's like also feels like pajamas. And I think it's just got me in a, I don't know, in a mood to say bonjour. Angela, when I first saw you, I thought you were just wearing a
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好闺蜜。现在，我们为你带来了独家的《办公室》重温播客节目。每周，我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。欢迎收听办公室女郎。Bonjour。Bonjour。我不知道。我不知道。我穿着这件T恤，它有点像那种非常柔软闪光的面料，但感觉也像睡衣。我觉得它让我有了一种，我不知道，想说bonjour的心情。安吉拉，当我第一次看到你时，我还以为你只是穿了一件
black t-shirt and I was really disappointed because I showed up in my Pam teapot shirt for our recording. Why I like to always wear an office ladies or office themed or use an office mug when we record. I don't know. It's a thing. It's like, you want to get in the mindset. Here's the thing, guys. Every single week, Jenna shows up, we hop on the Zoomie Zoom because that's our life right now. And she has on an office themed something, shirt, hoodie. And you did this also when we would use to go in the studio. You would always have your hoodie. And today I was like, I better dress to match my lady friend. Well, I thought you were wearing a black t-shirt and then you started dancing to our theme
黑色T恤，我真的很失望，因为我录制时穿的是我的潘茶壶T恤。为什么我录音时总是喜欢穿办公室女郎主题、办公室主题的衣服，或者用办公室的杯子呢？我不知道。这是一种习惯。就好像，你想进入状态。事情是这样的，伙计们。每周，珍娜都会出现，我们会在Zoomie Zoom上连线，因为这就是我们现在的日常生活。她总会穿一件带有办公室主题的衣服、衬衫或连帽衫。以前我们去录音室时你也会这样。你总是穿着你的连帽衫。今天我想，我最好也穿得跟我这位女伴搭一点。好吧，我还以为你穿的是黑色T恤，结果当我们的主题曲播放时，你开始跟着跳舞
song when it played. And I saw that it says office ladies. I was so happy. And then it made you speak French. So what wait, what are we, what are we here to talk about, Jenna? We are here to talk about initiation season three, episode five, written by BJ Novak and directed by Randall Einhorn. There are a lot of good quotes in this one. I won't rapid fire them right now, but there's some good quotes. Angela, last week when we did grief counseling, we had a lot of bird injuries and fiascos in our life. Has any type of initiation incident happened to you this week? Have I been initiated in my own house? Yeah. I mean, talk about an interesting topic if the answer is yes. No, but don't give my kids any ideas.
。我看到上面写着“办公室女郎”。我太高兴了。然后这让你说起了法语。等等，我们今天是来聊什么的，珍娜？我们是来聊第三季第五集《新人培训》的，由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，兰德尔·艾恩霍恩执导。这一集里有很多精彩的金句。我现在就不连珠炮似地说出来了，但确实有一些很棒的金句。安吉拉，上周我们做丧亲咨询时，我们生活中经历了很多小鸟受伤的趣事和混乱。你这周有没有发生什么类似“新人培训”的事件？我在自己家里被整了吗？对啊。我是说，如果答案是“有”，这绝对是个有趣的话题。没有，不过可别给我家孩子出什么主意。
They would be all over this. They'd be like, here's the thing, kid club initiation. Go into Isabel's room, put on this fuzzy hat, jump backwards three times, make a duck sound. You're in the club. Sounds fun. I'm into it. All right. Let's talk about this episode. I've got a summary for you. I'm very excited. This is a big episode. All right. Here's the main storyline. Dwight is taking Ryan on his first sales call, but it's not as simple as that. Of course it's not. It involves Dwight. It involves a trip to Dwight's farm and other places. And his creepy cousin. Oh, we're going to meet Moe's. And then of course back at Dunder Mifflin, lady, it's pretzel day. That's a big day. Big day. Stanley is so excited.
他们肯定会玩疯的。他们会说：“事情是这样的，儿童俱乐部的入会仪式。走进伊莎贝尔的房间，戴上这顶毛茸茸的帽子，向后跳三次，学一声鸭叫。你就加入俱乐部了。”听起来挺好玩的。我挺感兴趣的。好了。我们来聊聊这一集。我为你准备了一份总结。我超级兴奋。这可是一集大制作。好了。主要剧情是这样的：德怀特带着瑞恩去进行他的第一次销售拜访，但事情没那么简单。当然没那么简单。这其中涉及德怀特。这涉及去德怀特农场的旅程以及其他地方。还有他那毛骨悚然的表弟。哦，我们要见莫斯了。然后当然是回到邓德米弗林，各位，今天是蝴蝶饼日。那可是个大日子。大日子。斯坦利太兴奋了。
It's a long line, but they're going to get some pretzels. However, at this same time, Jan has told Pam she has to keep a log of Michael's day and make sure he's productive. Hmm. Meanwhile, over in Stanford, they've got a squeaky chair. They've got some more flirty flirt. Oh boy, let's get into it. Fast fact number one, as I said, we are going to visit shrewd farm. This is huge. We got a ton of questions about this. Are you ready for some names? I'm ready for some names. Who wrote in Lauren Bales, Mike Motherwell, Jessica Cohen, Bailey Lawrence and Brianna Bullard all said, where is the farm? Where is the farm where Ryan and Dwight go? Well, I know that it was a few places. Did you hit
队伍排得很长，但他们能吃到蝴蝶饼。然而，与此同时，简告诉潘，她必须记录迈克尔一天的行程，确保他的工作效率。嗯。与此同时，在斯坦福分公司，他们有一把吱吱作响的椅子。他们有更多的调情。哦，天哪，我们开始吧。趣味事实一，正如我所说，我们将造访施鲁特农场。这太重磅了。我们收到了大量关于这个的问题。你们准备好听听都有谁来信了吗？我准备好听名字了。谁来信了？劳伦·贝尔斯、迈克·莫瑟韦尔、杰西卡·科恩、贝利·劳伦斯和布里安娜·布拉德都问了：“农场在哪里？瑞恩和德怀特去的那个农场在哪里？”好吧，我知道它取景于好几个地方。你查过
up some kentipedia? I did. So the main shrewd farm was shot at the Disney Ranch, which is also called the Golden Oak Ranch. It is a place where you shoot things. It's like an outdoor exterior shooting studio, basically. It's massive, though. It's massive. It's acres and acres, right? It's like, oh, yeah, it's massive. And so so many movies that need this sort of rustic look have been filmed there. Like the history of Disney Ranch is really cool. Oh yeah. It's located in New Hall, California, which is about 17 miles from the Dundermifflin Studios. I'm giving you that detail because several people asked how far away it was from our main studios. And I want them to feel satisfied. So there are several barns and
肯特百科了吗？我查了。所以，主要的施鲁特农场是在迪士尼牧场拍摄的，它也被称为金橡树牧场。这是一个你可以在那拍摄各种场景的地方。它基本上是一个户外外景拍摄工作室。不过它非常巨大。它非常巨大，有几英亩又几英亩对吧？就像，哦，对啊，它超级大。所以许多需要这种乡村风格的电影都在那里拍摄。迪士尼牧场的历史真的超酷。哦，对。它位于加利福尼亚州纽霍尔，距离邓德米弗林工作室大约17英里。我提供这个细节是因为好几个人问它离我们的主要工作室有多远。我想让他们感到满意。所以那里有几个谷仓和
farmhouses on this property. They chose one of them to be the shrewd farmhouse. And then they created a graveyard next to it. But you might be thinking, wait a second, I don't remember a graveyard. That's because it's a deleted scene. It's a deleted scene. It's a really good deleted scene, you guys. If you have the DVDs, go watch it. So here's, here's what happens. They're in the cemetery because Dwight wants to show Ryan how many shrewds have actually been buried on shrewd farms. And he has like his grandfather's tombstone and he's like, my grandfather was a good man, but did very bad things. So what is up with his grandfather? His grandfather was, I don't know, not maybe not a great guy. Then Dwight
农舍。他们选择了其中一个作为施鲁特农场的主农舍。然后他们在旁边建了一个墓园。但你可能会想：“等等，我怎么不记得有个墓园？”那是因为它是一个被删减的片段。是一个被删减的片段。伙计们，这是一个非常棒的被删减片段。如果你有DVD，去看看吧。所以，事情是这样的。他们在墓地里，因为德怀特想向瑞恩展示究竟有多少施鲁特家族的人被埋葬在施鲁特农场。他还立了他爷爷的墓碑，他说：“我爷爷是个好人，但做过非常糟糕的事。”那么他爷爷到底怎么了？他爷爷是个，我不知道，也许不是个绝佳的好人。然后德怀特
finds like an empty, it looks like a beer can and he gets furious and he starts looking around and he sees these, this couple, the guy like basically has no clothes on. He's like covering himself with his pants and a girl who barely is clothed and they start running through the field and Dwight's yelling at them. And this was awesome because it's a total callback to office Olympics where Dwight mentions that teenagers sometimes use the beat farm for sex. Oh, I'm so bummed this is not in the episode. It's a great scene. It's a really funny scene. I love a callback and this is calling back creepy grandfather and the teenagers on the
发现了一个空的，看起来像啤酒罐的东西，他勃然大怒，开始四处张望，接着他看到了这两个人，那个男的基本上没穿衣服。他用裤子遮住自己，还有一个几乎没穿衣服的女孩，他们开始在田野里奔跑，德怀特冲他们大喊大叫。这太棒了，因为这完全呼应了“办公室奥运会”那一集，德怀特提到过青少年有时会利用甜菜农场来偷尝禁果。哦，这没有出现在正片里，我太失望了。这是一个很棒的场景。这是一个非常搞笑的场景。我喜欢前后呼应，这里呼应了那个诡异的爷爷和农场里的青少年。
farm. And you know what, when I watched it, all I could think about since I filmed many scenes on Troop Farms was the field they ran through. A, it was probably super hot and B, it was sneaky. We'll get to that later. But all I could think of was these people with not a lot of clothes on having to run through that sneaky field. I was like, oh, yes, let's talk about those snakes, Angela, because Kent told me that the one requirement for shooting on the ranch is that every production has to hire a snake wrangler. Yeah, because the property has a history of rattlesnakes on the property. Yeah. And Kent said the snake guy found a rattlesnake near that graveyard set. A five foot rattlesnake,
你知道吗，当我看到这一幕时，由于我在施鲁特农场拍摄过很多场景，我脑子里想的全都是他们奔跑过的那片田地。首先，那里可能超级热；其次，那里有蛇。我们稍后再聊这个。但我脑子里想的全都是这些衣着单薄的人不得不跑过那片充满蛇的田地。我就想：“哦，耶，让我们来聊聊那些蛇吧，安吉拉。”因为肯特告诉我，在牧场拍摄的一个硬性规定就是每个剧组都必须聘请一位捕蛇专家。对，因为该物业历来有响尾蛇出没。对。而且肯特说，那个抓蛇的人在那个墓地布景附近发现了一条响尾蛇。顺便说一句，是一条五英尺长的响尾蛇。
by the way. Oh, I, I don't doubt it. I don't doubt it. My memory is you, Angela. My height. I have two more facts about Disney Ranch. Let's hear it. So the other location that we shot on Disney Ranch was that barn. Mm hmm. That old barn. We also used that. And we used another house at the Disney Ranch for that scene at the bar at the end when Dwight and Ryan are at the bar. That house that they used for the bar was originally built for Pee Wee Herman's show back in the 1980s. And they redressed it and turned it into a bar. Isn't that amazing? That's crazy. I know. So there's a little fun fact. Yeah. And finally, a lot of people wanted to know if we did keep going back to the same location
哦，我，我对此深信不疑，深信不疑。我的记忆就是你，安吉拉。我的身高。关于迪士尼牧场，我还有两个事实。说来听听。我们在迪士尼牧场的另一个取景地就是那个谷仓。嗯哼。那个老谷仓。我们也用了那个。我们在迪士尼牧场还用了另一座房子，就是最后德怀特和瑞恩在酒吧里的那个场景。那座被用作酒吧的房子最初是为20世纪80年代Pee Wee Herman的节目建造的。他们重新装饰了一下，把它变成了一个酒吧。是不是很神奇？太疯狂了。我知道。所以这是一个有趣的小事实。对。最后，许多人想知道我们是否年复一年地回到同一个地点
to shoot year after year. And yes, we went back to the Disney Ranch multiple times, including in season four, the money episode. That is when Pam catches moes in the outhouse. Yeah. And so we were there. Dwight and Angela have a scene in that barn years later, but then ultimately we'll get to this. The final Shroop Farm scene of the whole series is in a whole new location that was so beautiful, but we'll get there. Yeah. That was gorgeous. It looked like we were in Scotland. It was so beautiful. Yes. But we don't go there till the end. Till the end end. Okay, guys, we'll get there in three years. We'll get there. Fast fact number two, the beat fields were not shot at Disney Ranch. That was a
进行拍摄。是的，我们多次回到迪士尼牧场，包括第四季的《金钱》那一集。那是潘在户外厕所抓到莫斯的时候。对。所以我们在那儿。几年后，德怀特和安吉拉在那个谷仓里有一个场景，但最终，我们会讲到这点的。全剧最后一个施鲁特农场的场景是在一个全新的地点，美极了，不过我们会讲到那里的。对。那真是美极了。看起来就像我们在苏格兰一样。太美了。是的。但我们要到最后才会去那里。到真正的最后。好吧，伙计们，我们三年后会到那里的。我们会去的。趣味事实二，甜菜地不是在迪士尼牧场拍摄的。那是一个
completely different location. Those scenes were shot at the Underwood Family Farm in Moorpark, California. It is a real working 200 acre farm. They grow corn, carrots, kale, strawberries, tomatoes, and of course, beets. So we filmed those in an actual beat field. Isn't that crazy? That is crazy. I have been to that farm with Isabel, my daughter for a school field trip, and I went on a hayride through like all around. Oh yeah. It's like a, it's a huge farm and it's just, it's not that far away. All right. Moving us along to fast fact number three, this was the first episode directed by Randall Einhorn and you guys. So Randall was our cinematographer and our A-camera operator. You've heard us talk
完全不同的取景地。这些场景是在加利福尼亚州莫尔帕克的安德伍德家庭农场拍摄的。这是一个真正运营的、占地200英亩的农场。他们种植玉米、胡萝卜、羽衣甘蓝、草莓、西红柿，当然还有甜菜。所以我们是在一个真正的甜菜地里拍摄的。是不是很疯狂？这太疯狂了。我和我女儿伊莎贝尔为了学校的实地考察去过那个农场，我还坐着运草车兜风参观了整个农场周围。哦，对。它就像一个巨大的农场，而且离这儿不远。好了。接下来我们来看趣味事实三，这是兰德尔·艾恩霍恩执导的第一集，伙计们。所以兰德尔曾是我们的摄影师和A机摄像师。你们听我们谈论过
about him a lot. We loved him. We loved him. He was just so fun. And this was a, this was like a big deal. Like the cast was so excited to see Randall direct an episode. I got on the phone with Randall, Angela. You did. I love him. Yes. And we're going to have him on the show. He told me that this was his first directing job ever. He told me that before our show, he had only ever worked on documentary style projects. And remember we said he was a camera operator on Survivor? Yeah. But he had done all this other documentary work as well. Yeah. He used to film like, I think like river boat, crazy river rafting stuff in Australia. Like he is like a tough guy. And, and I think the documentary style, like
他很多次。我们爱他。我们太爱他了。他超级有趣。这可是一件大事。剧组看到兰德尔执导一集都兴奋极了。我和兰德尔通了电话，安吉拉。你打了。我爱他。是的。我们打算请他上节目。他告诉我这是他有生以来第一份导演工作。他告诉我，在我们的节目之前，他只参与过纪录片风格的项目。还记得我们说过他是《幸存者》的摄像师吗？对。但他之前也做过所有这些其他的纪录片工作。对。他以前拍过，我想是澳大利亚的河上木筏漂流那种疯狂的东西。他就像个硬汉。而且，我认为这种纪录片风格，正如
we said, was perfect for our show. And now he gets to direct. Yeah. He said he couldn't believe he got the job as our cinematographer because he had never worked in scripted anything before. And now Greg was telling him to direct and he was like, what? But he said that Greg was really sweet. Greg said, Randall, all the time you are finding jokes with your camera. And this is a natural extension of that. And so Randall was like, all right, I'll do it. And he said he was so touched because he felt like everyone in the cast and crew was rooting for him to succeed. He said he'll just never forget what that support felt like and what it meant to him. He said, especially BJ, who was the writer of the episode. He said the
我们所说，对我们的节目来说简直完美。现在他终于可以当导演了。对。他说他简直不敢相信自己能得到我们摄影师这份工作，因为他以前从来没有做过任何有剧本的东西。现在格雷格却让他当导演，他当时就想：什么？但他说格雷格真的很好。格雷格说：“兰德尔，你一直在用你的镜头发现笑话。这是对这一点的自然延伸。”所以兰德尔就想：“好吧，我来干。”他说他非常感动，因为他觉得剧组和幕后所有人都支持他获得成功。他说他永远不会忘记那种支持的感觉以及它对他的意义。他说，尤其是BJ，他是这一集的编剧。他说
hardest part of directing this episode, because I said to him, I'm like, Randall, this was a huge episode. You have to introduce pretzel day, shrewd farms and moes. And then it all ends with this epic phone call between Jim and Pam. What was the hardest part of all that? And he said the hardest part was not holding the camera himself. Well, yeah. Yeah, that's so true. Because that was his background for years, you know, but I think it made him such a great director because he had that vision. He knew where he wanted the camera. He knew it. He wanted the camera to see. I love that. Well, he said he did take the camera a few times during this episode and he even pointed
执导这一集最难的部分，因为我对他说：“兰德尔，这一集太重磅了。你得介绍蝴蝶饼日、施鲁特农场和莫斯。然后这一切以吉姆和潘之间这通史诗般的电话收尾。”所有这些里面最难的部分是什么？他说最难的部分是自己不能亲自扛着摄像机。哦，对。对，确实如此。因为那是他多年的背景，你知道的，但我认为这让他成为了一位如此伟大的导演，因为他有这种愿景。他知道他想把摄像机放在哪里。他知道。他想让摄像机看到什么。我太喜欢了。不过他说他在这一集里确实拿了几次摄像机，甚至还
them out to me. So I'll tell you those moments as we go along and then he also told me that even today when he's directing, because that's what he does now, he's now a director exclusively. And he said it was only last year that he finally directed a project and didn't take the camera once. Wow. But he said that's how he he feels it that way still because those were his beginnings. Yeah. Well, before he directed this episode, he directed the webisodes. And so, you know, obviously, that's not like a full episode, but I remember how giddy he was. But he was holding the camera and directing because that was that was just us on the weekend. It was just like three of us there. And you guys
向我指出了那些时刻。所以等我们讲到时我会告诉你们这些时刻的，然后他还告诉我，即使在今天当他执导时，因为他现在专门做导演了，他现在是一名全职导演。他说直到去年他终于执导了一个项目，却一次都没有拿过摄像机。哇。但他说他依然对那种感觉念念不忘，因为那是他的起步。嗯，在他执导这一集之前，他执导过网络剧。所以，你知道的，显然，那不是完整的一集，但我记得他当时有多兴奋。但他一边扛着摄像机一边导演，因为那只是我们在周末拍摄。当时现场就我们三个人。而你们
won an Emmy for those webisodes. We did. We won an Emmy. I have an Emmy for the accountants. It just tickles me. So cool. All right. Listen, why don't we take a break and then we're going to come back and start breaking down this episode. Okay. Okay. So now we're in the episode, guys. And Dwight is challenging Ryan to a brain teaser. And you know, Ryan just crushes it. He knows all of them. Dwight gets really frustrated. I found this little piece of trivia on Dunderpedia. And Jenna, I loved it. Dunderpedia is amazing. If you guys haven't checked it out, everybody. All right. So on Dunderpedia, it says, one of the riddles that Dwight poses to Ryan in the cold open is about a boy involved in
凭借那些网络剧赢得了一座艾美奖。我们确实赢了。我们赢得了一座艾美奖。我为《会计师》赢得了一座艾美奖。这真让我感到好笑。太酷了。好了。听着，我们为什么不休息一下，然后回来开始剖析这一集。好的。好的。好了，伙计们，现在我们进入正片了，德怀特正在用脑筋急转弯考瑞恩。你知道的，瑞恩直接秒懂。他全都知道。德怀特沮丧极了。我在邓德米弗林百科上发现了这则冷知识，珍娜，我太喜欢了。邓德米弗林百科太棒了。如果你们还没看过，大家都去看看吧。好的。所以邓德米弗林百科上说，
a car accident who is the son of the doctor on the call in the emergency room and therefore cannot operate even though his father was in the car and was also injured because the doctor is his mother, right? Yes. Get this at the very end of the finale of the original BBC series. Tim, which you know, the character Jim is based on, along with Gareth, and that's the character Dwight was based on, is being asked this riddle by David Brent. Wow. Isn't that so cool? I feel like this is a little nod, right? Yeah. I loved that. I love that too. Well, then when this episode really begins, Jan is in Michael's office. She's trying to have a professional conversation with Michael, but he keeps making it personal. Yeah. Jenna,
德怀特在冷场时抛给瑞恩的谜语之一，是关于一个卷入车祸的男孩，他是急诊室里接听电话的医生的儿子，因此不能为主刀，尽管他的父亲也在车里并且也受伤了，因为医生是他的母亲，对吧？是的。你猜怎么着？在英国广播公司（BBC）原版剧集大结局的最后，吉姆这个角色的原型蒂姆，以及加雷斯——那是德怀特角色的原型，正在被大卫·布伦特问这个谜语。哇。是不是超级酷？我觉得这是一个小小的致敬，对吧？是的。我也很喜欢。我也很喜欢。嗯，然后当这一集真正开始时，简在迈克尔的办公室里。她试图和迈克尔进行一次专业的对话，但他总是把它搞得很个人化。对。珍娜，
did you notice her hair in this scene? How can you not? What is going on with her hair? I don't know. It's like they tried something new. They tried rollers or something. It looks like hot rollers. It looks like hot rollers. I was just like, wait, they were just doing blowouts. And now Jan is judging it up when she comes in to see Michael now. That's an interesting take on it. Like he's talking about the sex he's having with Carol, and she's like, I did not hot roller my hair for this, for this BS. Yeah. I totally noticed her hair. Well, then Jan goes up to Pam's desk and says that she needs to keep an hourly log of Michael's activity so that corporate can analyze his productivity. You guys, there's
你注意到她在这一场戏里的头发了吗？怎么可能注意不到？她的头发是怎么回事？我不知道。就好像他们尝试了新发型。他们用了发卷什么的。看起来像热发卷。看起来像热发卷。我当时就想：等等，他们之前明明一直留着吹风造型的。现在简来见迈克尔时居然把头发弄卷了。这是一个有趣的解读。就像他在谈论他和卡罗尔之间的性生活，而她心里想的是：我可不是为了这个、为了听这些废话才特意用热发卷弄头发的。对，我绝对注意到她的头发了。嗯，然后简走到潘的桌子旁，说她需要每小时记录一次迈克尔的活动，以便公司能分析他的工作效率。伙计们，
a moment in this scene that made me laugh so hard when I was rewatching it. And also, I remember breaking every time Melora did it. She walks up to the desk. I'll tell you. She walks up to the desk and she's like, hi, Pam. And Pam goes, hi. And then she goes, I'm great. And then keeps talking, but Pam didn't say, how are you? Yeah. She's so pissed that Michael has just told her about Carol and she just walks up with that energy. I love it so much. So you know, I got the shooting drafts for this whole season. And it's in there. I'm great is in there. I had to look it up to see if Melora improvised that or if it was written, but that was a written joke. And I love it. So good. We had some
这场戏里有一个时刻，我重看的时候笑得前仰后合。而且，我还记得每次梅洛拉做那个动作时我都会笑场。她走到桌子前。我来告诉你们。她走到桌子前说：“嗨，潘。”潘说：“嗨。”然后她说：“我很好。”接着继续说话，但潘根本没问“你最近怎么样”。对。她气坏了，因为迈克尔刚刚跟她聊了卡罗尔，她就带着那种情绪走过来了。我太喜欢了。所以呢，你知道的，我拿到了这一整季的拍摄剧本。台词就在里面。“我很好”这句台词是写好的。我特意查了一下，想看这是梅洛拉即兴发挥的还是剧本里写的，但这确实是剧本里写好的笑话。我太喜欢了。我们收到了
mail about this scene. Lauren Hallman wrote in to say at one minute 47 seconds, there's a weird circular object in the bottom right next to an ancient stapler that I can't identify. And Elizabeth Molina said, what's the deal with the scale behind Jenna? It looks like a food scale, which would make more sense in the kitchen or break room. I think they're talking about the same object. I froze on it. Yeah. It is a scale. I think it's a scale that Pam is using to weigh small packages for mailing. Yeah, I would think it was probably to make sure she has the right postage. That's what it looked like to me. Yeah, we don't have a mail room in our office. We have a mail cart. So I guess Pam has to keep that scale
一些关于这场戏的观众来信。劳伦·霍尔曼来信说，在1分47秒时，一个古老的订书机旁边，右下角有一个奇怪的圆形物体，我认不出来。伊丽莎白·莫利纳说：“珍娜身后的那个秤是怎么回事？它看起来像个食物秤，在厨房或休息室里可能会更有意义。”我想他们说的是同一个东西。我特意把画面定格了。对。那是一个秤。我觉得那是潘用来称寄信的小包裹用的秤。对，我想这可能是为了确保邮资正确。看起来就是这样的。对，我们办公室里没有收发室。我们有一个信件手推车。所以我想潘必须把那个秤放在
behind her, but it's not always there. Listen, we don't know what Pam does back there with her revolving plants and her scale. She can't keep a plant alive. She has a giant shredder. Yeah. And now she has a scale. We don't know. We don't know. Well, guys, now we are going to find out that Dwight is taking Ryan on this sales call, his first sales call. Oh, he's so excited. There are some great deleted scenes on the DVD that are all about the storyline. But Dwight is so excited. He's hoping that Ryan will become part of the Dwight's army of champions, right? Yeah. Not be a slacker like Jim. This is like, and maybe become one of his best friends. Maybe. So in the DVDs, there's a deleted scene that I absolutely
她身后，但它并不总是在那儿。听着，我们不知道潘在她那转动的植物和秤后面都干些什么。她连一盆植物都养不活。她有一个巨大的碎纸机。对。现在她还有一个秤。我们不知道。我们真的不知道。好吧，伙计们，现在我们发现德怀特正带着瑞恩去进行这次销售拜访，他的第一次销售拜访。哦，他太兴奋了。DVD上有一些很棒的被删减片段，全都是关于这条故事线的。但德怀特太兴奋了。他希望瑞恩能成为德怀特的冠军军团的一员，对吧？对。不要像吉姆那样偷懒。这就像是，说不定还能成为他最好的朋友呢。也许吧。所以在DVD里，有一个我绝对
loved. I laughed so hard, and it's just such a simple moment, you guys. But Michael goes to hug Ryan, to wish him well as he goes out for his first sale. You know, like, I'm gonna give you a man hug. It's awkward. It's so awkward. But then it gets even weirder because then Dwight joins in and he wants to hug him too. And then Michael's like shoving Dwight, like, Dwight, get away. Like, meanwhile, like, BJ is like stuck between them. It is, it's, it just made me laugh so hard. I love this whole storyline. We know you love it too. We have a surprise. We have a surprise. Tell them, Jenna, rain and BJ are going to come on the show today to talk all about it. So we're going to break down the rest of the
喜欢的被删减片段。我笑得前仰后合，伙计们，这只是一个非常简单的时刻。但迈克尔去拥抱瑞恩，祝他第一次外出销售一切顺利。你知道的，就像，我要给你一个猛男抱。这很尴尬。超级尴尬。但接下来更诡异的是，德怀特也加入了进来，他也想抱抱瑞恩。然后迈克尔开始把德怀特推开，就像，德怀特，滚开。与此同时，BJ就像被夹在他们中间一样。这，这真的让我笑得前仰后合。我太喜欢这条故事线了。我们知道你们也很喜欢。我们有个惊喜。我们有个惊喜。告诉他们，珍娜，雷恩和BJ今天会来节目聊聊这一切。所以我们将剖析剩余的
episode. And then when they hop on, they will discuss all things shrewd farms and the initiation. Yes, we're going to skip their scenes for now. But don't worry, we will get to it. For now, let's discuss what's going on at Stanford. Oh yeah, at three minutes, 21 seconds. Karen notices that Jim took her chair and has replaced it with the squeaky chair. I want you to know something. Squeaky chair was not in the original script. Huh. The original storyline for Stanford was completely different. This was a late edition. And I traded some texts with BJ and he said he doesn't quite remember where the squeaky chair storyline came from.
剧集。然后等他们连线时，他们将讨论施鲁特农场和新人培训的一切。是的，我们暂时先跳过他们的场景。但别担心，我们一定会讲到的。现在，让我们来讨论一下斯坦福分公司发生了什么。哦，对，在3分21秒时。凯伦发现吉姆拿走了她的椅子，换成了一把吱吱作响的椅子。我想让你们知道一件事。吱吱作响的椅子并不是原剧本里的。哦。斯坦福原本的故事线完全不同。这是一个临时的改动。我和BJ发了短信，他说他不太记得吱吱作响的椅子这条故事线是从哪里来的。
Let me give you a little pitch where it might have come from and it might not have. But I want you guys to know something happening behind the scenes was over in the accounting department and I texted Oscar. I was like, Oscar, do you remember this? And he just wrote back, ha, ha, ha, ha. Okay. There was a crap chair over in accounting. It was an absolute piece of crap chair that it wouldn't go up and down. It just was like set on one setting. So it was always way too low for my desk. And then it leaned way too far back. So you always felt like, like, I mean, you guys, I know I'm Southern, but I always felt like I was going to get bucked out of it. I'd be like, that's the chair is going to buck
让我给你们讲一个小插曲，它可能就是灵感来源，也可能不是。但我想让你们知道，幕后发生的一件事是在会计部门那边，我给奥斯卡发了短信。我说：“奥斯卡，你还记得这个吗？”他直接回了我：“哈哈哈哈哈。”好吧。会计部门那边有一把烂椅子。那绝对是一把彻头彻尾的烂椅子，它无法升降。它就固定在一个高度上。所以对我的办公桌来说，它总是太低了。而且它还总是往后倾斜得厉害。所以你总是觉得，伙计们，我知道我是南方人，但我总是觉得自己会被它从上面颠下去。我会想，这把椅子要把我
me out. So sometimes I would go and it would be at my desk and I'd be like, son of a gun, Oscar switched it again. It just treated back and forth between me and Oscar. I would move his chair and I'd put the crap chair at his desk. And then out of nowhere after lunch, it would be back at my desk and I'd be like, Oscar, you gave me this piece of crap chair again. We must have done this, I think for weeks. And then one day I moved it over to Creed's desk. Oh no, Angela. I did. And I said to Oscar, I was like, I put it, I put that crap chair at Creed's desk and we like laughed. And anyway, it just cracks me up that this was actually something happening. I don't know if the writers ever even knew
颠出去了。所以有时我会过去，发现它在我的办公桌前，我就会想：“该死的，奥斯卡又调换了。”它就在我和奥斯卡之间换来换去。我会搬走他的椅子，把那把烂椅子放在他的办公桌前。然后不知从哪儿冒出来，午饭过后，它又回到了我的办公桌前，我就会说：“奥斯卡，你又把这把破椅子给我了。”我们肯定这么干了好几个星期。然后有一天，我把它搬到了克里德的办公桌前。哦不，安吉拉。我真的这么干了。我对奥斯卡说：“我把那把烂椅子放到克里德的办公桌前了。”然后我们笑得不行。不管怎样，这实际上是正在发生的事情，这让我觉得好笑极了。我不知道编剧们是否
about it. I don't know if we vented about it. But this was an actual thing happening over and accounting. Oh my gosh, you had your own chair war. We did. But I don't know how Brian stayed out of it. Maybe because he was too far in the corner. Yeah. It just, it just traded between me and Oscar. Well, did you notice in this scene in Stanford when, when Jim wheels his chair over to the copier? Did you look in the background? I noticed a little something back there. I, I saw a few people right in. You have to tell them because I think this is so beautiful. All right. I also talked to Randall about this and he said this was totally on purpose. He planted a guy standing at reception in the
知道这件事。我不知道我们是不是一直在抱怨这个。但这是会计部门那边真实发生的事情。天哪，你们居然有自己的椅子大战。我们确实有。但我不知道莱恩是怎么置身事外的。也许是因为他坐在角落里太远了。对，它就在我和奥斯卡之间换来换去。好吧，你们有没有注意到斯坦福的这场戏里，当吉姆把他的椅子滑到复印机旁时？你们有没有看背景？我注意到了背景里的一个小细节。我，我看到有几个人来信提到了。你必须告诉他们，因为我觉得这太美妙了。好吧。我也和兰德尔谈过这件事，他说这绝对是故意的。他刻意安排了一个人站在接待处，
same way that Jim would always stand at reception and talk to Pam. He even has his sleeves rolled up the way Jim used to roll up his sleeves, sleeve gate. Susan, are you listening to this, Susan? Yeah, I know. Susan who broke down the sleeves. Yeah. And Randall said that was on purpose to, to keep that Pam Jim thing sort of in our orbit. Oh my gosh, it's such a beautiful detail. So Stanford has their own version of Jim and Pam that hang out at reception and flirt. Yeah. Amazing. That's amazing. That's amazing. All right. So let's go back to the Scranton branch. Pam is keeping notes on Michael's day. He's on a phone call and he's doing a Bill Cosby impression. So Pam holds up her log and she has written Cosby
就像吉姆以前总是站在接待处和潘聊天那样。他甚至把袖子卷起来的方式都和吉姆以前卷袖子的一模一样——“袖子门”。苏珊，你在听吗，苏珊？对，我知道。就是那个分析袖子卷法的苏珊。对。兰德尔说那是故意的，为了让潘和吉姆的那种氛围继续存在于我们的视野中。天哪，这是一个多么美好的细节。所以斯坦福有他们自己的版本的吉姆和潘，会在接待处闲逛并调情。太棒了。这太棒了。太棒了。好了。那么让我们回到斯克兰顿分公司。潘正在记录迈克尔一天的行程。他正在通电话，还在模仿比尔·科斯比。所以潘举起她的记录本，上面写着“模仿科斯
impression. So first of all, that is not my handwriting on the log. People asked. And also we got a fan question from Jonathan Barak. When Jan gives Pam a time sheet to write down everything Michael does throughout the day, why doesn't Pam cover for him? Like why not write down sales call instead of Cosby impression? Hmm. What are our thoughts on that? I mean, Pam sometimes has a little bit of a stickler. She's a role follower, you know. Yeah. I mean, I think if she covers for Michael and then Jan finds out otherwise, Pam's going to get in trouble. Yeah. I mean, I feel like she does cover for him later. So maybe she starts out being like, all right, I'll do what Jan told me. But then she feels bad or something
斯比”。首先，记录本上的字不是我的笔迹。大家都在问。而且我们还收到了来自乔纳森·巴拉克的一个观众提问：当简给潘一张时间表，让她写下迈克尔一整天所做的一切时，潘为什么不帮他打掩护？比如，为什么不写“销售拜访”而不是“模仿科斯比”呢？嗯。我们对此有什么看法？我是说，潘有时有点一板一眼的。她是个循规蹈矩的人，你知道的。对。我是说，我觉得如果她帮迈克尔打掩护，结果被简发现了，潘就会惹上麻烦。对。我是说，我觉得她后来确实帮他打掩护了。所以也许一开始她是抱着“好吧，我会照简说的做”的心态。但后来她觉得内疚什么的，
because Michael is such a train wreck for the whole day. Yeah. And he ends up making a huge sale in the end. So his that's the thing about Michael, right? Like his weird ways they, they turn out he's able to connect with people. He is. Say what you want to say about Michael. People like him, not that have to work with him. Yeah. Equations is really like him. All right, now we're back at the Stanford branch and Andy, I guess, has told Karen he'll try to help her, you know, get that chair back. So he's like, Jim, can you come talk to me over here? And he's like, I can talk to you from here. And he's like, yeah, but could you get up and come over here? And Karen's like, that's all you got. And
因为迈克尔这一整天简直就是个灾难。对。而且他最后居然做成了一笔大单。所以迈克尔就是这样的人，对吧？就像他那些古怪的方式，最后总能证明他有能力与人建立联系。他确实能。不管你怎么说迈克尔。人们确实喜欢他，虽然不用和他共事的人更喜欢他。方程组真的很喜欢他。好了，现在我们回到了斯坦福分公司，安迪我想他已经告诉过凯伦，他会尽量帮她把那把椅子拿回来。所以他说：“吉姆，你能过来跟我聊聊吗？”吉姆说：“我从这儿就能跟你聊。”安迪说：“对，但你能站起来过来一下吗？”凯伦说：“你就这点本事啊。”然后
then Ed is Andy made me laugh so hard when he says, I'm acting my heart out here. I mean, Andy is so bad. He's so transparent. And it just was so funny that he was like, hey, come on. That seems like an ed improv to me, but I couldn't check because this story line isn't in my script. We did have a fan catch at this moment. Marguerite Carter wrote in to say at around four minutes, 50 seconds, you can see Jim's name plate on his desk. And it says Jim Halpert. And underneath it, it says assistant regional manager, Marguerite. There you go. Applause. Applause. It's official. Well, things are about to get real exciting over the Scranton branch because it is announced. It's pretzel day. Oh, and Stanley books it
埃德——安迪说的那句“我在这里可是拿出了全部演技在演呢”，让我笑得前仰后合。我是说，安迪太烂了。他太假了。他那样说“嘿，过来呀”简直搞笑极了。这看起来像是埃德的即兴发挥，但我没法核实，因为这条故事线不在我的剧本里。在这个时刻，我们确实抓到了一个粉丝彩蛋。玛格丽特·卡特来信说，在大约4分钟50秒时，你可以看到吉姆桌上的名牌。上面写着“吉姆·哈尔珀特”。在它下面写着“助理地区经理”，玛格丽特。就是这样。掌声。掌声。实锤了。好吧，斯克兰顿分公司接下来要有好玩的事情发生了，因为广播通知了。今天是蝴蝶饼日。
out the door. He books it, but he grabs his crossword. Well, he knows, he knows he's going to be in line. Yeah, yeah, he's planning ahead. He's ready for it. I have a question. And this was also a fan catch. Kelly Rue asked, whose voice makes the announcement about pretzel day? And Bailey Aspenson said, is that the voice of Billy Merchant? It is. It's Billy Merchant. Yes. Which makes sense because he's the building manager. Yeah, I asked Kent Subornac because there was a part of me that thought, is that Kent's voice? And Kent said, no. Kent said they got Marcus York to record that audio for the announcement. Amazing. I love it. I love the attention to detail. I do too. So now we have the Stanley talking head. That
哦，斯坦利冲出了门。他冲了出去，还不忘抓上他的填字游戏。好吧，他知道，他知道自己得去排队。对，对，他提前做好了计划。他已经准备好了。我有个问题。这也是一个粉丝彩蛋。凯莉·鲁问：“播报蝴蝶饼日通知的声音是谁的？”贝利·阿普森说：“那是比利·麦 Merchant 的声音吗？”是的。是比利·麦Merchant的声音。是的。这很合理，因为他是大楼经理。我问过肯特·苏伯纳克，因为我心里曾闪过一个念头：那是肯特的聲音吗？肯特说：“不是。”肯特说他们找了马库斯·约克来为这个通知录音。太棒了。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这种对细节的关注。我也很喜欢。
is one of my favorite talking heads and Leslie's delivery of it is so great. He says, I wake up every morning in a bed that's too small, drive my daughter to school that's too expensive, and then I go to work for a job which I get paid too little. But I'm pretzel day. Well, I like pretzel day. That talking head that appears in the episode is an alternate talking head Angela. That is not the talking head that was in the shooting draft. It's so perfect though. I can't imagine anything else. I mean, it's so perfect. It sums up like Stanley. What was it? The original talking head was this. There are four things that I love. My wife, my daughter, Pam Greer, and a hot chewy roll of butter dough. Pam Greer. All right.
所以现在是斯坦利的主角独白。那是我的最爱的主角独白之一，莱斯利对它的演绎太棒了。他说：“我每天早晨醒来，睡在一张太小的床上，开车送女儿去一所太昂贵的学校，然后去上一份工资低得可怜的工作。但是到了蝴蝶饼日。嗯，我喜欢蝴蝶饼日。”剧集里出现的这段独白其实是一个备选独白，安吉拉。那并不是拍摄剧本里原本的独白。不过它太完美了。我无法想象其他的台词。我是说，它太完美了。它完美概括了斯坦利。原本的独白是什么？原本的独白是这样的：我最喜欢四样东西。我的妻子、我的女儿、帕姆·格里尔，以及一个热乎乎、有嚼劲、裹着黄油的面团。帕姆·格里尔。好吧。
Fan question from Crystal White. Who came up with the idea of pretzel day and were there actually pretzels for the cast to eat on set? Thank you so much for your question, Crystal. Okay, so we got a lot of pretzel related questions. And Jenna, I know you did some digging around and you got the real deal on this. Yes, I found out some good stuff. First off, BJ told me that the inspiration for pretzel day goes all the way back to season one. Greg took the writers on these fact finding visits to real offices so that they could get inspiration for storylines and episodes. I love that. Now, I know that Greg likes to do stuff like this. I know when he was working on King of the Hill, he took all the writers to Austin,
来自克rystal White的粉丝提问：是谁想出了蝴蝶饼日这个主意，片场真的有蝴蝶饼给演员们吃吗？非常感谢你的提问，克rystal。好吧，所以我们收到了很多关于蝴蝶饼的问题。珍娜，我知道你做了一些深入了解，并且弄清了这背后的真相。是的，我打听到了一些好消息。首先，BJ告诉我，蝴蝶饼日的灵感可以追溯到第一季。格雷格曾带着编剧们去真实办公室进行实地考察，以便为故事线和剧集寻找灵感。我太喜欢了。现在，我知道格雷格喜欢做这种事。我知道当他在制作《乡巴佬 Hill》时，他带着所有编剧去了得克萨斯州奥斯汀，
Texas, because they were like, okay, you got to know Texas if you're writing about characters that live in Texas. So I love that Greg is now taking our writers to small businesses. Yes. And lady, he even took them to a paper company. Oh my God. Amazing. Yes. And BJ told me that on one of the days when they went to this office park, they were doing some kind of morale boosting free food giveaway for the employees. It wasn't pretzels. He thinks maybe it was popcorn, but everyone was really excited. And the writers put this idea on a card in the writer's room. And then BJ added the tidbit that Stanley would be the character that looked forward to this free food giveaway all year. I love that. I love that so much.
因为他们觉得：“好吧，如果你要写生活在得克萨斯州的角色，你必须了解得克萨斯州。”所以我很喜欢格雷格现在带我们的编剧去参观小企业。是的。而且，伙计们，他甚至带他们去了一家纸业公司。天哪。太神奇了。是的。BJ告诉我，有一次他们去这个办公园区时，那里正在为员工举办某种旨在提升士气的免费食物赠送活动。不是蝴蝶饼。他觉得可能是爆米花，但每个人都兴奋极了。编剧们把这个主意写在编剧室的一张卡片上。然后BJ添加了一个有趣的细节，即斯坦利会是那个整年都盼着这个免费食物赠送活动的角色。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
And it's so relatable. You know, years ago, I worked as an operator, Jenna. And we would have make your own ice cream sundae day and they would wheel a cart around. You couldn't leave your desk. You had to like stay on calls. It was kind of crazy. But the managers would wheel around this cart and we would get so excited to make our own ice cream sundaes. And I feel like I relate to Stanley on this day. He loved pretzel so much. He looked forward to it so much. Okay, Angela, I feel like we had something similar on our set because we would every once in a while get a coffee cart. Oh, people would lose their minds for that coffee cart. And you would line up outside and you would get to order your gourmet coffee.
而且这太接地气了。多年以前，我曾做过话务员，珍娜。我们会举办“自制冰淇淋圣代日”，他们会推着小推车到处走。你不能离开座位。你必须一直在通话。这有点疯狂。但经理们会推着这个小推车到处走，我们做自己的冰淇淋圣代时会兴奋得不得了。我觉得我在这一天特别能对斯坦利感同身受。他太爱蝴蝶饼了。他太盼望它了。好的，安吉拉，我觉得我们在片场也有过类似经历，因为我们偶尔会弄到一个咖啡车。哦，大家为了那个咖啡车简直要疯了。你会排在外面，然后你可以点你的精品咖啡。
Because on the set, we really just had that drip coffee because they took our fancy machine away for being too loud. Oh, yeah, it was too loud. So when we would get a coffee cart and they would come and set up in the parking lot, I mean, the line was around the corner. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. So this is very relatable. And I love this storyline. I also found out about the pretzels. Oh, where were they from? Kent told me that the pretzels were from Wetzel's pretzels. He said that they rented a pretzel cart from a prop house and Phil Shea decorated it and sort of tricked it out. And they had pretzel toppings just like in the script. You could have sweet pretzel, maple pretzel. I wasn't in any of the pretzel
因为在片场，我们其实只有那种滴漏咖啡，因为我们的高档咖啡机因为太吵而被没收了。哦，对，声音太大了。所以每当有咖啡车来停车场搭设时，我跟你说，队伍都拐了好几个弯。哦，对。哦，对。所以这非常接地气。我太喜欢这条故事线了。我还打听到了关于蝴蝶饼的事。哦，它们是哪来的？肯特告诉我，那些蝴蝶饼是来自威茨蝴蝶饼店。他说他们从道具仓库租了一个蝴蝶饼手推车，菲尔·谢伊对其进行了装饰和精心改造。而且他们真如剧本里写的那样准备了蝴蝶饼的各种配料。你可以选甜味蝴蝶饼、枫糖蝴蝶饼。我没有参演任何排队买蝴蝶饼的戏份，但我确实记得那一天，因为拍完戏后，他们把所有多余的蝴蝶饼都放到了剧组休息室。所以皮特给大家留了那些。
line scenes, but I do remember that day because after the scenes, they put all the extra pretzels over at Crafty. And so Peter had them for everyone. Yeah, I remember that too. Kent told me that they had ordered 100 pretzels, but we only used a few for the actual scene and that all the leftovers went to Crafty and that between the cast and crew, we ate them all. We did. We had our own pretzel day, guys. We did. We had our own pretzel day. So now we're in the pretzel line and Kelly is chatting up Michael. So he's tuning her out and he's laser focused on his pretzels. And by the way, Phyllis is about to come up to the line and she's doing that thing where like, Oh, I'm just saying hi. She's just saying
对，我也记得那个。肯特告诉我，他们原本订了100个蝴蝶饼，但实际拍摄只用了几个，剩下的全去了休息室，然后剧组演员和工作人员硬是把它们全吃光了。我们确实吃了。我们过了我们自己的蝴蝶饼日，伙计们。我们确实过了。我们有了自己的蝴蝶饼日。所以现在我们在排队买蝴蝶饼，凯莉正在跟迈克尔闲聊。但他完全不搭理她，把注意力百分之百集中在蝴蝶饼上。顺便说一句，菲利斯正要走到队伍前面，她假装在打招呼：“哦，我只是打个招呼。”她只是跟队伍里的鲍勃打个招呼。我只是跟我家那口子打个招呼，然后我要插队了。
hi to Bob in line. I'm just saying hi to my to my fella and then I'm going to sneak in line. Yes. And oh my gosh, Michael and Stanley are not having it. They are booing her. They start booing her. They tell her to get to the back of the line. I mean, and then they high five. Michael and Stanley high five. I mean, is it the only time in the whole series they high five? They're like friends in this episode. It's a really cute thing. They are friends for a moment, a moment in time on pretzel day. All right, so back to squeaky chair. Karen in Stanford, she is purposely squeaking her chair to annoy Jim. Love me, love me, say that you love me. Yeah. And then Jim tries to get love full stuck in her head.
然后哦天哪，迈克尔和斯坦利可不吃这一套。他们开始嘘她。他们开始发出嘘声。他们叫她去队尾排队。我的天，然后他们击掌了。迈克尔和斯坦利击掌了。我是说，这是整部剧里他们唯一一次击掌吗？在这集里他们简直成了朋友。这真的很可爱。他们在蝴蝶饼日这天，在某个时刻成为了朋友。好了，回到吱吱作响的椅子。斯坦福的凯伦，她故意让椅子发出吱吱声来烦吉姆。“爱我，爱我，说你爱我。”对。然后吉姆试图把一首歌塞进她脑子里让她挥之不去。
Now Randall pointed out the camera work to me here. This is one of the moments where Randall took the camera back because he wanted to do this all in one shot, just changing the focus from Karen to Jim and then pulling back to reveal Andy and again, changing the focus between these three different people. He said he couldn't explain it. He just had to shoot it. I love that. I love that he can just be like, I got this guys. I got it. Let me, let me pick up this camera. Well, on the DVD commentary, they were talking about how much John broke in the scene. They said every time Ed would do a version of, you know, singing the song, John would break. And then they said that Ed started messing with John, trying
现在兰德尔向我指出了这里的摄影机位。这是兰德尔重新拿回摄像机掌镜的时刻之一，因为他想一气呵成完成这个镜头，只需把焦点从凯伦切换到吉姆，然后拉远镜头展现安迪，接着再次在三个不同的人之间切换焦点。他说他没法解释，他就是得这么拍。我太喜欢了。我喜欢他那种“伙计们，这个我来，我搞得定。来，把这个摄像机给我”的气魄。好吧，在DVD评论音轨里，他们谈到了约翰这场戏里笑场了多少次。他们说每次埃德唱那首歌时，约翰都会笑场。然后他们说埃德开始捉弄约翰，试图在演唱方式上“加码”，看能不能把约翰逗笑。但我太喜欢了。我猜约翰当时简直一团糟，因为埃德演得太棒了。
to sort of like up his game on how he would do it just to see if he could get John to break. But I just love that. I guess John was kind of a mess because Ed was just crushing it. All right. So now Stanley, you know, he's getting his pretzel. It's here. Yes. He's at the front of the line. He's moving away. Now there was a line that got deleted here. It's in the script and it's Stanley's pretzel order. A lot of people want to know what was his order. I don't know what his order was. What was his order? Salty with extra mustard. I did not see that coming. Yeah. Salty with extra mustard is Stanley's pretzel. Okay. Well when Michael gets to the front of the line, there are just too many toppings for
好了。现在斯坦利，你知道的，他拿到他的蝴蝶饼了。饼来了。是的。他在队伍最前面。他走开了。这里其实有一句被删减的台词。它在剧本里，是斯坦利的蝴蝶饼订单。很多人想知道他的订单是什么。我不知道他的订单是什么。他的订单是什么？要咸的，多加芥末。我完全没料到。对，咸的加多点芥末就是斯坦利的蝴蝶饼。好吧，当迈克尔走到队伍最前面时，那里的配料实在太多了
him to choose from. There are 18 different sweet toppings. He's like a child. He is like a child. And I was so impressed with the actor that plays the pretzel guy because he just rifles off all of those extras like it's nothing. And you know, he had to memorize all of that. Do you want to hear what they are? There's 18 of them. Yeah. All right. They are sweet glaze, cinnamon sugar, chocolate, white chocolate, fudge, M&Ms, caramel dip, mint chip, chocolate chip, marshmallow nuts, toffee nuts, coconuts, peanut butter drizzle, Oreos, sprinkles, cotton candy bits and powdered sugar. Oh my gosh. And Michael gets the works. Oh my God. We had a fan question about this. God in this chilies wrote in was the pretzel guy an actor
让他挑选。有18种不同的甜配料。他就像个孩子。他就像个孩子。我对扮演椒盐卷饼摊贩的演员印象深刻，因为他一口气报出所有这些加料，就像小事一桩一样。你知道的，他必须把所有这些都背下来。你想听听都有什么吗？有18种呢。行。好吧。它们是甜糖釉、肉桂糖、巧克力、白巧克力、奇巧巧克力、M&M豆、焦糖酱、薄荷巧克力碎、巧克力豆、棉花糖果仁、太妃糖果仁、椰丝、花生酱淋酱、奥利奥、糖针、棉花糖碎和糖粉。噢，天哪。迈克尔点了豪华全套。噢，天哪。我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问。天哪，这个叫Chilies的网友写道，那个椒盐卷饼摊贩是个演员
or someone from craft service or someone from the crew. He was an actor and his name was Thomas F. Evans. And he is, he has done a ton of guest appearances on television shows. He's done The Kids Are All Right, Criminal Minds, General Hospital, Days of Our Lives. Oh my God. Days of Our Lives. You've probably seen him everywhere. Days of Our Lives, Angela. Ah, well Thomas, I thought you were fantastic. And I just thought you were the perfect pretzel guy. There's a deleted scene here. Oh yeah, there is. Oh yeah, there is. It's more of the Michael Stanley friendship. And it's kind of too bad that it got cut because it's a scene in the parking lot of Michael and Stanley eating their pretzels together. They're
还是制片组杂务人员，或者剧组里的其他人。他是个演员，名叫托马斯·F·埃文斯。他演过，在许多电视剧里客串过大量角色。他演过《The Kids Are All Right》、《犯罪心理》、《综合医院》、《我们的日子》。噢，天哪。《我们的日子》。安吉拉，《我们的日子》。你可能到处都能看到他。《我们的日子》，安吉拉。啊，好吧，托马斯，我觉得你棒极了。我觉得你就是完美的椒盐卷饼摊贩。这里有一个被删减的片段。哦，是的，确实有。哦，是的，确实有。那是更多关于迈克尔和斯坦利友谊的内容。被剪掉有点可惜，因为那是迈克尔和斯坦利在停车场一起吃椒盐卷饼的场景。他们
so happy. Michael says they taste so good in my mouth. And Stanley goes, that's what she said. I'm so sad that was cut. I am so sad the scene was cut. They shared it. That's what she said. Joke. And then back in the kitchen, there is one more Stanley pretzel moment that's deleted. And that's in the kitchen. Kevin has gotten his pretzel and he gets distracted looking in the fridge for like a topping. And Stanley just swipes the pretzel. That's amazing. He steals Kevin's pretzel. Well now lady, we're on a scene that I have a lot of questions about. Oh, okay. We are in the break room. And it's you and Kelly. Yeah. And Kelly is very worried because Ryan has been gone all day and she hasn't heard from him. We know
太高兴了。迈克尔说，这在我的嘴里尝起来太美味了。然后斯坦利说，她刚才就是这么说的。我很遗憾这个片段被剪掉了。我很遗憾这个场景被剪掉了。他们分享了这个。那是她说的。笑话。然后回到厨房，还有一个被删减的斯坦利的椒盐卷饼的高光时刻。那是在厨房里。凯文拿到了他的椒盐卷饼，但他分心了，在冰箱里找什么配料。而斯坦利顺手拿走了那个椒盐卷饼。太棒了。他偷了凯文的椒盐卷饼。好了，女士，现在我们要聊一个我有很多疑问的场景。噢，好吧。我们在休息室。
where he is. He's off with Dwight. But she's worried you're eating something that's not a pretzel. It is not a pretzel. I zoomed in on this. Okay, so listen at 10 minutes 57 seconds. I am pretty sure I'm eating popcorn. Huh. I think I have a handful of popcorn. I am wondering because sometimes we shot out of order if this was some of the leftover popcorn from the coup that had been set out. I'm sure they popped you fresh popcorn for this scene. No, I'm just saying maybe we grabbed it from Crafty. Oh, perhaps. Perhaps. Well, we got a fan question also about this scene from Natalie. Was this the first Kelly and Angela scene? Well, you know what? I think it's the first time they've sat down together.
里面有你和凯利。是的。凯利非常担心，因为瑞恩一整天都不见踪影，她也没有他的消息。我们知道他在哪里。他和德怀特在一起。但她担心你在吃不是椒盐卷饼的东西。那不是椒盐卷饼。我把这个画面放大了。好吧，听着，在10分57秒的时候。我很确定我在吃爆米花。呵。我想我抓了一把爆米花。我在想，因为有时候我们拍摄顺序是打乱的，这会不会是上次政变时摆出来剩下的爆米花之一。我确信他们为这场戏给你爆了新鲜爆米花。不，我只是说也许我们是从后勤部拿的。哦，也许吧。也许吧。好吧，关于这个场景，我们也收到了娜塔莉的一个粉丝提问。这是凯莉和安吉拉的第一场对手戏吗？好吧，你知道吗？我觉得这是她们第一次坐在一起。
I mean, it's definitely a huge Kelly Angela moment. It wasn't that long ago that Kelly got drunk in the Christmas episode and tried to kiss Dwight and Angela Martin. I mean, Angela Martin was not having it. No. So it's kind of a big deal that she even tries to comfort Kelly, you know? Yeah, you even pat her hand. You make physical contact. I make physical contact. Then she says that Dwight is weird. And then I say he's not. And then she says he's a freak. And I'm like, you're a freak. And I storm off. I wrote in my journal that I was really excited to do this scene because Mindy and I never got to do scenes together. But I said that Mindy broke into laughter every single time I glared at her.
我的意思是，这绝对是凯莉和安吉拉的一个重头戏。就在不久前，凯莉在圣诞节那集里喝醉了，试图吻德怀特和安吉拉·马丁。我的意思是，安吉拉·马丁根本不吃这一套。不。所以她甚至试图去安慰凯莉，这算是一件大事了，你知道吗？是的，你甚至轻拍她的手。你有身体接触。我有身体接触。然后她说德怀特很怪。然后我说他才不怪。然后她说他是个怪胎。然后我说，你才是怪胎。然后我气冲冲地走了。我在日记里写过，我非常高兴能拍这场戏，因为明迪和我从来没有一起拍过对手戏。但我在日记里说，每次我怒视明迪时，她都会笑得前俯后仰。
Mindy was the worst. Mindy was the worst. I have so many stories coming up of doing scenes with Mindy where you would say a regular line and she would start laughing. I didn't even say a line. I just looked at her like really snarky and she start laughing. Well, we have a fan catch Angela from Jennifer Wells. Guess what you do in this scene, Angela? I know. You get up and you leave, taking only your water, leaving your food behind again. I should have never made such a big deal when Pam did it because apparently my character does it all the time. You know why, Angela? Because people do it all the time. People do it all the time. Do they? You get so mad you leave your food on the table? Yes, you've lost your
明迪是最糟糕的。明迪是最糟糕的。我有很多接下来和明迪对戏的故事，你只要说一句平常的台词，她就会笑起来。我甚至都没说台词。我只是用非常刻薄的眼神看着她，她就笑了起来。好吧，我们有一个来自詹妮弗·韦尔斯的粉丝抓包安吉拉。你猜你在这一幕里做了什么，安吉拉？我知道。你起身离开了，只拿了你的水，再次把食物留下了。当帕姆这样做的时候，我真不该小题大做，因为显然我的角色一直在这样做。你知道为什么吗，安吉拉？因为人们总是这样。人们总是这样。是吗？你气得把食物留在桌上？是的，你已经气得
appetite because you're so angry. That's an indication of how upset you are. You just walk away. If you are in the middle of dinner with someone and you are compelled to walk away from the table, you don't also bring your dish. Although it would be very funny if you did. I think I would be like, I'm done talking to you but I'm not done eating. I'll eat this in another room. I think comedically I want to write myself a scene sometime in a show or improvise a moment where I get really furious and I leave the table but I pack up everything in anger. I pack it all up but I take it with me. That would be amazing especially if it took you a very long time to pack it up. Yeah, and everyone had to just
没有胃口了。这表明你有多生气。你只是走开。如果你正和某人吃晚饭，并且你不得不离开餐桌，你不会顺便把你的盘子也带走。虽然如果你这么做了会非常搞笑。我想我会觉得，我跟你说完了，但我还没吃完。我要去另一个房间吃这个。我觉得在喜剧效果上，我想在某个节目里给自己写一场戏，或者即兴发挥一个时刻：我气急败坏地离开桌子，但我在愤怒中把所有东西都打包带走了。我把它们全打包了，但我要带走。那太棒了，尤其是如果你花很长时间才把它们打包好的话。是的，每个人都必须坐在
sit there and watch. They have to wait. Yeah, I had to spoon things into a Tupperware. I had to find the lid. I had the wrong lid. We're on to something here. We're on to something. Well, back at Stanford, Andy is now the owner of the squeaky chair. Andy basically would be the creed. He got the crap chair. He did. He's been creeded. So now we're back at Scranton. Michael's playing music. He's got this sugar high going, right? Yeah. And he's playing that song. Hey. At 13 minutes 36 seconds, my character is annoyed. She's annoyed at the music. Kevin's into it. He's thumping his pin. In real life, in real life, Jenna pressed in. Our old boom operator was videoing between scenes, all of us dancing. And he got a video
那里看着。他们必须等着。是的，我得把东西一勺一勺舀进特百惠保鲜盒里。我得找盖子。我还拿错了盖子。我们说到点子上了。我们说到点子上了。好吧，镜头回到斯坦福，安迪现在成了吱吱作响椅子的主人。安迪基本上就是克里德。他拿到了那把烂椅子。他确实如此。他被克里德化了。所以现在我们回到了斯克兰顿。迈克尔在放音乐。他现在正处于糖分亢奋的状态，对吧？是的。他在放那首歌。嘿。在13分36秒的时候，我的角色很不耐烦。她对音乐感到厌烦。凯文很投入。他在敲打着笔。现实生活中，现实生活中，詹娜按下了。我们的老Boom收音师在两场戏之间用摄像机拍下了我们所有人跳舞的画面。他拍到了一段
of Creed and I dancing to this in between takes. And it's no way. Yes, it's a little blurry because he said he did it on a flip phone. And he texted it to Matt Sohn, our B camera operator who sent it to me. Guys, check Office Ladies Pod Instagram for this amazing behind the scenes video. It's a little blurry. It's a little blurry because it was a flip phone, but Creed and I are dancing our hearts out between takes. But Angela Martin and not so much. Well, when Michael comes out of his office after he's done dancing, he decides to maximize everything. And he's talking a mile a minute. And we had a fan question from Claudia Cano, who wants to know, was that speech when he's talking a million
克里德和我在这两场戏的间隙随着音乐跳舞的视频。而且根本没有。是的，画面有点模糊，因为他说他是用翻盖手机拍的。然后他把视频发给了马特·松，我们的B机摄像师，马特又发给了我。伙计们，快去Office Ladies播客的Instagram上看这段精彩的幕后视频吧。画面有点模糊。画面有点模糊，因为是用翻盖手机拍的，但克里德和我一直在两场戏的间隙跳舞。而安吉拉·马丁则没那么投入。好吧，当迈克尔跳完舞从办公室出来后，他决定将一切效果最大化。他喋喋不休地说个不停。我们有一个来自克劳迪娅·卡诺的粉丝提问，她想知道，他当时像连珠炮似的那段演讲
miles an hour improvised? I checked the script. No. Like, maybe two words were different than what was scripted. Way to go, Steve. Way to go, Steve. Way to go, Steve. And then we had a fan question. A lot of people want to know, Angela, Sarah Quick, Grace and Allie and Sarah and Janelle and Jakey all want to know what topping we would put on our pretzel. I mean, Jenna, I just like the basic. I just like like Stanley, I like salty pretzel and give me a little side of some kind of spicy mustard and I'm happy. Oh, really? This is interesting to me. I am cinnamon sugar. Mm hmm. I think it's interesting that you like a salty pretzel and I like a sweet pretzel, but I'm probably the salty person and you're
是即兴发挥的吗？我查了剧本。没有。也许只有两个词跟剧本写的不一样。干得好，史蒂夫。干得好，史蒂夫。干得好，史蒂夫。然后我们有一个粉丝提问。很多人想知道，安吉拉，莎拉·奎克、格蕾丝、艾莉、莎拉、珍妮尔和杰基都想知道我们会把什么配料放在椒盐卷饼上。我的意思是，詹娜，我只喜欢最基础的。我只喜欢，就像斯坦利一样，我喜欢咸味椒盐卷饼，再给我来一点某种辣芥末，我就很满足了。哦，真的吗？这对我来说很有趣。我喜欢肉桂糖。嗯哼。我觉得很有趣，你喜欢咸味的椒盐卷饼，而我喜欢甜味的椒盐卷饼，但可能我是那个脾气暴躁的人，而你是那个
the sweet one. That's not true. Oh, I am way saltier. Please. Please. I'm half cremogen. All right. I have a question for you, Jenna. Yeah. On the DVD commentary, BJ says that the line direction where Michael crashes out, you know, he falls asleep on a kush ball. And he really does. He's face planted on his desk. His face is on a kush ball. He said that that was direction written in the script. Do you have that? What does it say exactly? It says in the script, Pam looks through the blinds into Michael's office. It's not good. Michael is fast asleep, face on a kush ball. I love that. And then later it notes when it's time to leave for the day. It says Michael stumbles out of his office, squinting with
甜美的人。才不是呢。哦，我脾气暴躁得多。拜托。拜托。我有一半是老顽固。好吧。我有一个问题要问你，詹娜。是的。在DVD评论音轨中，BJ说，迈克尔崩溃时的舞台指导是这样的：你知道的，他趴在一个库什球（kush ball）上睡着了。他确实这么做了。他面朝下趴在办公桌上。他的脸贴在一个库什球上。他说那是写在剧本里的导演指示。你有那个吗？具体是怎么写的？剧本里写着，帕姆透过百叶窗往迈克尔的办公室里看。情况不妙。迈克尔睡得很死，脸贴在一个库什球上。我太喜欢这个了。然后后面注明了该下班离开的时候。上面写着迈克尔踉踉跄跄地走出办公室，眯着眼睛，
kush marks on his face. And they put the marks on his face. That was someone in here in makeup had to make kush ball, like marks on his face to make his cheek red. I love this moment. And I caught a little something. Now you guys know we have young children. So I am watching every animated movie out there multiple times. And our kids love Despicable Me. They love Despicable Me. They love Minions. We've watched it over and over. And it's 16 minutes 52 seconds. And Michael says with the jello, I swear I hear grew from Despicable Me. I will give that to you. I think it's early grew. Listen to it. So now we have a very big scene to end this episode. Yeah. Pam's got her coat on. She's done for the day. She's leaving.
脸上印着库什球的痕迹。他们把那些痕迹画在脸上了。当时剧组负责化妆的人必须做出像库什球一样的痕迹印在他的脸上，好让他的脸颊变红。我太喜欢这个时刻了。而且我发现了一件小事。现在你们都知道我们有年幼的孩子。所以我把现有的每一部动画电影都看过好几遍了。我们的孩子非常喜欢《神偷奶爸》。他们非常喜欢《神偷奶爸》。他们喜欢小黄人。我们一遍又一遍地看。在16分52秒的时候。迈克尔拿着果冻说话时，我发誓我听到了《神偷奶爸》里格鲁的声音。这个我算你赢。我觉得那是早期的格鲁。听听看。所以现在我们要以一场非常重大的戏来结束这一集。是的。帕姆穿好了外套。她今天的工作完成了。她要走了。
She's got her phone rings. You guys. It's Jim. It is Jim. He called the main line because he couldn't remember Kevin's extension. He wants to talk to Kevin about fantasy football. Pam explains she's still at work because Jan told her to do this log about Michael. And they start to have a conversation. First of all, Jenna, you and John as actors are so fricking good in the scene. This scene wrecked me. Your expression on your face when you realize it's his voice and the same with John. It's so beautiful. Your conversation is so organic and earnest. And oh, my God, it gave me all the feels. And I want to know, was it all scripted or did you guys get to play around a little bit in that? It was mostly
她的电话响了。伙计们。是吉姆。真的是吉姆。他打到了总机，因为他不记得凯文的分机号了。他想和凯文聊聊梦幻足球。帕姆解释说她还在工作，因为简让她做这份关于迈克尔的工作日志。然后他们开始交谈。首先，詹娜，你和约翰作为演员，在这场戏里真的太棒了。这场戏把我击垮了。当你意识到那是他的声音时，你脸上的表情，约翰也是一样。太美了。你们的对话是那么自然、真诚，噢，天哪，让我有了所有的感觉。我想知道，这全都是按剧本演的，还是你们俩在里面稍微自由发挥了一下？大部分是
scripted, but there was also a lot of improvisation. So I'll kind of, I'll break it down for you. But I want to say that first of all, this is the first time that John and I had done a scene together. And we're not even face to face, but this is the first time we had performed together in months. Because this was our fifth episode in, but we'd also had our long summer break. And when I was watching this scene, oh, my gosh, all of this sense memory came back to me. And I remember what it was like to shoot this, we spent hours shooting this scene. Let me say too, we had a lot of people right in a lot of people, I will say them, Anna Beatrice Alexandra, Eva Lee, Gracie Nina, they all want to know
按剧本演的，但也有很多即兴发挥。所以我大概给你们拆解一下。但我首先要说的是，这是约翰和我第一次演对手戏。而且我们甚至都不是面对面，但这确实是我们几个月来第一次一起表演。因为这是我们拍的第五集，但我们刚度过了漫长的暑假。当我看到这个场景时，噢，天哪，所有的感官记忆都涌了上来。我记起了拍摄时的情景，我们花了好几个小时拍摄这场戏。我也得说，我们有很多人写信来，有很多人，我要把他们的名字说出来：安娜、比阿特丽斯、亚历山大、伊娃·李、格蕾西、妮娜，他们都想知道
if John and I were actually talking on the phone during our conversation, because we've talked a lot about how usually if you're talking on the phone to someone, they're not really there, you're just pretending. Yes. This felt like you were Jenna. We were. Were you? Yes, you were. We were. Oh my God. Okay, so you're reacting to each other in real time. You heard each other's voices in real time. This was really rare. We only did this a couple of times on our set, but here's what happened. Randall told me that he requested that we be able to hear one another, but not just that he wanted to shoot both sides of the conversation at the same time. And this was really complicated because the Stanford set
在对话期间，约翰和我是否真的在通电话。因为我们讨论过很多次，通常如果你在和某人打电话，对方其实并不在那里，你只是在假装。是的。这个感觉就像你在打电话一样，詹娜。我们是的。是吗？是的，你是。我们是的。噢，天哪。好吧，所以你们是在实时对彼此做出反应。你们实时听到了对方的声音。这真的很罕见。我们在片场只这样拍过几次，但情况是这样的：兰德尔告诉我，他要求我们能够听到彼此的声音，不仅如此，他还想同时拍摄对话的双方。这非常复杂，因为斯坦福的片场
was in one building, and then there was a huge parking lot. And then the Scranton set was in another building. And he said he thinks that it was his inexperience as a director that led him to making this. What he realizes now was like a very bold, complicated request. Logistically, this was very hard to do. And he didn't realize that. No, he was like, hey, listen, when we do that scene with Jim and Pam, I'm going to want to be able to like have a camera on each of them. And I want them to be able to hear each other on the phone. And he says now looking back, he realizes what an insane request that was because here's what had to happen. Kent told me that NBC Universal IT came out. And they first they had to hook up
在一栋楼里，然后中间有一个巨大的停车场。接着斯克兰顿的片场在另一栋楼里。他说他认为正是他作为导演的经验不足，才导致他做出了这个决定。他现在意识到这是一个非常大胆、复杂的请求。从后勤角度来看，这很难做到。他当时并没有意识到这一点。不，他当时的想法是：嘿，听着，当我们拍吉姆和帕姆的那场戏时，我想在他们每个人身上都架设一台摄像机。我希望他们能在电话里听到彼此的声音。而他现在回想起来，意识到这是一个多么疯狂的请求，因为接下来必须发生这些事。肯告诉我，NBC环球公司的IT部门出动了。他们首先得把这两栋楼的电话线连接起来，
the phone lines from these two buildings so that John and I could talk to one another. He said that they put video village, which is where the video feed goes. It's a little tent with video monitors. And each camera goes into a different monitor so that the director can sit and see what the cameras are seeing. They had to build that in the middle of the two stages in a parking lot. They had to run phone lines. They had to build a tent full of monitors and make sure they had enough cable that those monitors could be active and working. Yes, because the cable goes from the monitor through the parking lot, through the building, all the way to the camera. Oh my gosh. So the director can see what was happening. Then they recorded audio on three
这样我和约翰才能互相通话。他说他们搭建了视频村（video village），也就是视频信号传输的地方。那是一个带有视频监视器的的小帐篷。每个摄像机都连接到一个不同的监视器上，这样导演就可以坐在那里看到摄像机拍到的画面。他们必须在两个舞台之间的停车场中央搭建这个。他们必须铺设电话线。他们必须搭建一个装满监视器的帐篷，并确保他们有足够的电缆，以便这些监视器能够保持活动和工作。是的，因为电缆从监视器穿过停车场，穿过大楼，一直延伸到摄像机。噢，天哪。这样导演就能看到发生了什么。然后他们在三条不同的线路上
different lines. They had a boom operator in with me. They had a boom operator in with John. And then they were able to record the actual phone conversation through the phone line. Oh my gosh. It's very technically difficult. But the result is beautiful. And it made all the difference for John and I to be able to hear one another and to be able to really talk. One of the things I love about your conversation, which made it feel so real, is that you guys, you're just jumping all around on all these different subjects, just having this conversation because you haven't talked to each other in so long. It's like all your thoughts are coming out. Yes. And in the script, there were these little time jumps. So in the way BJ wrote it out was so cool too, because he would
录制音频。他们在我这里安排了一个收音师。在约翰那里也安排了一个收音师。然后他们能够通过电话线录制实际的电话对话。噢，天哪。这技术难度非常大。但结果是完美的，对于约翰和我来说，能够听到彼此的声音并真正进行对话，这带来了所有的不同。我喜欢你们对话的一点是，它感觉如此真实，因为你们在所有这些不同的话题上跳来跳去，只是在进行对话，因为你们已经很久没有说过话了。这就像你们所有的想法都倾泻而出了。是的。在剧本里，有一些小的时间跨度跳跃。BJ写的方式也非常酷，因为他会
write stage direction that were things like Pam lingers wondering if she should have a seat. Will this phone call go on much longer? So it's like he gave me these things to play out. And then it would time cut to a new subject. So it's like we start talking about typing. But then when we time cut to the 28 days, 28 days later conversation, it says Pam is now seated. And then, you know, it gave us direction about our body language so that you see the passage of time that has happened in this conversation. You get the sense that I feel like this was like a 40 minute conversation. And then of course, it ends so awkwardly so abruptly and weird. Oh, I know. And it breaks your heart. It breaks your heart. But that's perfect to it's perfect to that they had this
写一些舞台指导，比如“帕姆逗留着，琢磨着自己是否应该坐下。这通电话还会持续很久吗？”所以这就好像他给了我这些可以演绎的东西。然后时间会剪辑到一个新话题。所以我们一开始聊打字。但当时间剪辑到《惊变28天》的对话时，上面写着帕姆现在坐下了。然后，你知道的，它给了我们关于肢体语言的指导，让观众看到这场对话中时间的流逝。你会觉得，我觉得这就像是一场40分钟的对话。然后当然，它以一种非常尴尬、非常突兀和怪异的方式结束了。哦，我知道。这让人心碎。这让人心碎。但这也是完美的，他们有过这个
moment. But then it got weird. So you know, they're not out of the woods here. They just got to hear each other's voice. And it felt like home for a little bit. But it was everything. It was everything. I loved it. I loved it. It just completely wrecked me. But you guys always wrecked me the gym and Pam stuff always gets me. Oh, man, I think more than any relationship on the show, it's the one that gets me every time. But I guess, you know, I'm not alone. Because that's everybody. All right, so I think we should take a break now. And when we come back, we are going to be talking with BJ Novak and Rainn Wilson. Oh my gosh, we're going to talk all things initiation. So come on back.
时刻，但后来变味了。所以你知道的，他们还没脱离困境。他们只是听到了彼此的声音。并且有那么一会儿感觉像回到了家。但这就代表了一切。这就代表了一切。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。它彻底把我击垮了。但你们总是把我击垮，吉姆和帕姆的桥段总是能戳中我。噢，天哪，我想比起剧中的任何关系，这都是每一次都能戳中我的那一个。但我想，你知道的，我并不孤单。因为所有人都是这样的。好吧，我觉得我们现在该休息一下了。等我们回来后，我们将和BJ·诺瓦克以及雷恩·威尔逊一起聊聊。噢，天哪，我们要把“入会”的事聊个底朝天。所以欢迎回来。
Hey, everybody, we're back and guess who's with us? It's BJ Novak and Rainn Wilson. Hey, you guys. Hey, office gentlemen and ladies. Welcome office gentlemen, office humans, office people, office people. Oh boy. Well, this is already fun. All right, BJ, let's get started. You wrote this episode, you perform in it, obviously, but you wrote it. Can you tell us a little bit about writing it? Sure. As I'm sure has been established on the show and or elsewhere, you know, the way that a writer's room works is it's very collective. And so while I wrote the episode in the sense that I was the point person on the episode, I wrote the first draft, I cared the most about it. I likely did more writing than anyone else on this particular one. That's sort of the way that taking
嘿，大家好，我们回来了，你们猜谁和我们在一起？是BJ·诺瓦克和雷恩·威尔逊。嘿，你们好。嘿，办公室的绅士和女士们。欢迎办公室绅士、办公室人类、办公室人民、办公室人民。噢，天哪。好吧，这已经很有趣了。好吧，BJ，我们开始吧。这一集是你写的，你在里面演出了，很显然，但你是编剧。能跟我们讲讲创作这一集的故事吗？当然。正如大家在节目中和/或其他地方所了解的那样，你知道，编剧室的运作方式是非常集体主义的。所以，虽然我是以这一集核心负责人的身份写了这一集，我写了初稿，我对它最上心，我可能比这一集中的任何人都做了更多的写作。这就是编剧室里轮流执笔的过程的运作方式。所以有很多东西、想法和台词之类的并不是我写的。而且有很多我不记得了。但我对这段时间的记忆非常零星。有时候我能以难以置信的细节记住事情。而我写过的剧集里，有些整条剧情线我几乎、几乎完全记不起来了。所以这可能是一个非常零碎的回忆。不过是的，我确实写了这一集。
turns process works of the writer's room. So there's plenty of things, ideas and lines and stuff that I didn't write. And there's a lot I don't remember. But my memory of this time is very sporadic. Sometimes I remember things in incredible detail. And there are entire plot lines in episodes I wrote that I just barely, barely recall at all. So this might be a very spotty recollection. But yes, I did write this one. That was a fantastic little monologue. And the whole time I just kept thinking, is the Starship Enterprise trying to summon BJ up to the ship? Did you guys hear that background noise ringing? Is your laundry done? That's the sound my washing machine makes. Yeah. Should we do it again? No, no, I think we should know. I think we should use
那是一段精彩绝伦的小独白。整个过程我一直在想，星际迷航号是不是在试图把BJ传送到飞船上去？你们听到背景里的噪声铃声了吗？你的衣服洗完了吗？那是我洗衣机发出的声音。好吧。我们要重来一遍吗？不，不，我觉得我们应该知道。我觉得我们应该把所有这些都用上。我觉得这些全都是宝藏。这些全都是宝藏。因为就像，你知道的，我们开着Zoom，背景里各种东西叮当响，简直快把我们逼疯了。看，雷恩，那真是一段精彩的独白。我们俩今天都很口齿伶俐。伙计们，你们太给力了。真的吗？背景里是不是有什么飞船在试图把某人传送上去？但其中肯定有部分是你写的。噢，是的，是的，是的。甚至剧本中的核心想法也是你说的：“我真的很想写这个，我跟这个很有共鸣。”所以它就被分配给了你，因为你对这一集的发展方向有感觉。是的，在这种情况下，好吧，在这种情况下，我觉得这是格雷格·丹尼尔斯和迈克
all this. I think this is all gold. This is all gold. Because it's like, you know what, we're zooming and shit me cray cray up in here with the things ringing in the background. See, that's a great monologue to rain. We're both articulate today. You guys, you showed up, you showed up. And did we ever there was some spaceship attempting to beam someone up in the background of that monologue? But surely there were chunks of it you wrote. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Even central ideas in the script in which you said, I would really like to write this, I connect with this. And so it was assigned to you because you had a feel for where you wanted the episode to go. Yeah, in this case, well, in this case, I think it was a combination of Greg Daniels and Mike
·舒尔的结合，他们想出了这个核心点子。也许我说过，德怀特应该让瑞恩入会，然后他们就顺着这个思路发挥了一下。我记得这集分配给我，是因为我是瑞恩，而不是因为我对这个故事着迷。但在编剧室里，分配剧集的原因可能非常武断。原因可能经常是因为你想出了最初的点子。也经常只是因为，轮到你了。你知道的，我们拍到第七集了，而你是那个已经有五集没分到剧集的编剧。在这种情况下，我想，是这样的：“哦，你是瑞恩。差不多轮到你了。”完美。我确实很喜欢它。而且我觉得德怀特用那三个词让瑞恩入会，这真是一个惊人的故事梗概，内容太丰富了。你知道，
Sher, who came up with spearhead of the idea. Maybe I said, Dwight should initiate Ryan and they ran with it a bit. I remember it being assigned to me because I was Ryan, as opposed to because I was obsessed with the story. But there can be very arbitrary reasons that you're assigned an episode in the writer's room. It can be, it's very often because you came up with the original idea. It's often just, it's your turn. You know, we're on episode seven and you're the writer who hasn't gotten one in five episodes. And in this case, I think it was, it was, oh, you're Ryan. It's around your turn. Perfect. I did like it. And I thought that Dwight initiates Ryan with, you know, those three words, it's just an amazing log line, just so rich. You know,
有时候我们花很长时间构思故事。现在我只是在聊编剧室的题外话，因为这是我第一次上Office Ladies，但我们快要离开了。当时很晚了。我们都提出了这些有一段话那么长的构思。我想这真的是，你知道的，我猜其他编剧可能会对这个感到生气，但在经历了这一切之后，我只是，我们正要离开，我对格雷格说，我有一个两个字的构思：酒水游轮。他说，我们就拍这个。所以有时候，最短的构思能表达最多的意思。顺便说一句，那是我对《酒水游轮》最后的贡献了。但是入会，德怀特让瑞恩入会，你知道的，你可以想象出太多画面了。好吧，我喜欢这个故事线开始的方式。我们实际上
one of the, sometimes we'd spend forever pitching stories. Now I'm just on a writer's room tangent because this is my first time on Office Ladies, but we're about to leave. It was late. We had all given these paragraph long pitches. And I guess this was really, you know, I imagine the other writers might have been mad at this, but after all of this, I just, we were about to leave. And I said, Greg, I got a two word pitch, booze cruise. And he said, we're doing it. So sometimes it's the shortest pitch that says the most. And by the way, that was my last contribution to booze cruise. But initiation Dwight initiates Ryan, you know, there's just so much you can picture. Well, I love how this storyline begins. And we actually
让山姆提取了音频剪辑，这样我们都可以听一下。这是你们在车里。瑞恩以为他是去开销售会议。但德怀特把他开到了甜菜田的正中间。我们来听听这段音频。那销售办公室在哪？当你准备好看到销售办公室时，销售办公室自然会呈现在你面前。你的旅程现在开始。我太喜欢了。你的旅程现在开始。你脸上的表情，BJ。当他，哦，BJ。是的，你有很多非常棒的表情。嗯，这就是为什么我认为雷恩和我是绝配，因为我是那种非常依赖反应的人。而雷恩是那种非常善于主动输出的人。你觉得在办公室里，我们俩的即兴表演风格是这样的吗，这公平吗？
asked Sam to pull the audio clip so we could all listen to it. This is you guys are in the car. Ryan thinks he's driving to a sales meeting. But Dwight has driven him into the middle of a beat field. Let's listen to the clip. So where's the sales office? When you are ready to see the sales office, the sales office will present itself to you. Your journey begins now. I love it. Your journey begins now. And the look on your face, BJ. When he, Oh, BJ. Yeah, you have a lot of really good looks. Well, this is why I think Rain and I were a very good pairing, because I am such a reactor. And Rain is such a generator. Do you think that's fair and sort of our improv styles in the office?
我觉得是的。我觉得是这样的。是的，这个设定的铺垫也棒极了。比如，你兴奋吗？你真的很兴奋吗？你超级超级兴奋吗？然后瑞恩说，我有点兴奋。而德怀特说，我兴奋极了。所以要知道，德怀特身上结合了绝地大师、70年代大卫·卡拉丁主演的电视剧《功夫》，以及其他任何电影，比如《龙威小子》里的“擦蜡、收蜡”等所有元素，还有所有关于入会的恐怖电影，它们全都在他脑子里乱作一团，就像一台爆米花机一样。他们展现出的那种狂热看点十足，非常有趣。好吧，你提到这个很有趣，雷恩，因为我确实觉得他所有关于入会的经验都是基于他看过的虚构
I think so. I think that's, I think that's out. Yeah, the setup to this was fantastic, too. Like, are you excited? Are you really excited? Are you super, super excited? And Ryan's like, I'm a little excited. And Dwight's like, I'm incredibly excited. And so to know that Dwight has a combination of Jedi Master and Kung Fu, the television show from the 70s with David Carradine, and any other movies, Karate Kid, Wax On, Wax Off, anything, he's in horror films about initiations, like, are all jumbled in his head, like, like a popcorn machine. And the, the excitement they're from is a lot of fun to watch. Well, it's funny you mentioned that, Rain, because I do think that all of his experience with initiation is based on fictional
作品。因为我有这一集的剧本，雷恩，你有一些被删减的单人访谈，你在里面谈到，通常情况下，比如兄弟会的家伙们会租下你的农场搞活动。每年他们都会弄一只山羊，你很想知道他们对那只山羊做了什么。所以就好像，你根本没有——那段被删减了。这挺遗憾的，不过，你知道，这种事时有发生。但这是真的。我想德怀特的唯一参考框架就是他看过的东西。他从未真正参与过入会仪式。不像瑞恩，他说他在大学时加入过兄弟会，他对这套非常熟悉。是的。是的，去甜菜田吧。德怀特让瑞恩在地上种下一颗种子。然后我们有了这句
things that he's watched. Because I have the script for this, and there are some deleted talking heads that you have, Rain, where you talk about how very often, like, guys from a fraternity rent out your farm for activities. And every year, they get a goat, and you would love to know what they do with that goat. So it's like, you have no, like, that got deleted. It's unfortunate, but, you know, that happens sometimes. But it's true. I think Dwight's only frame of reference are things he's watched. He's never actually participated in an initiation. Unlike Ryan, who says he was in a fraternity in college, and he's very familiar with this. Yeah. Yeah, let's go to the beat field. Dwight makes Ryan plant a seed in the ground. And then we have this
台词。正如你在地上种下一颗种子一样，我也要把我的种子种在你身上。雷恩，我觉得那是即兴发挥。我想是的。我想我是即兴说出来的，而且，你知道的，试探性又兴奋地走向BJ。就像，我们可以保留这个吗？然后BJ说，是的，我们可以保留。噢，这真是个绝杀。这是一个绝杀级别的即兴发挥。我记得太清楚了。而且，你知道的，这是，而且我说了，你知道的，我觉得你不知道自己在说什么，这，这太完美了。这太完美了。我绝不是想说这在质量上是完全对等的。我只想说，那是非常精彩的雷恩式的喜剧输出，而我作为一个习惯做反应的人，成了非常好的背景板。你知道的，我觉得主动输出型演员在节目中要宝贵得多，
line. Just as you have planted a seed in the ground, I'm going to plant my seed in you. Rain, I think that was an improvisation. I think it was. I think I improvised that and was, you know, tentatively and excitedly went to BJ. Like, can we keep that? And BJ was like, yes, we can keep that. Oh, it was a killer. It was a killer improv. I remember it so vividly. And, you know, this is, and I did, you know, I said, I don't think you know what you're saying, which is, which was perfect. It was perfect. I hardly mean to say it was equivalent all in its quality. All I mean to say is that was a very good rain generating comedy and me being a very good backboard for it as a reactor. You know, I think the generator is a way more valuable improviser to have on a show,
但这是一个非常棒的团队。但我非常生动地记得雷恩即兴说出那句台词的情景，因为出于极大的尊重，我当时把它视为对我这个编剧的一种“暴扣”，他竟然能当场想出一句台词，可能比我辛苦创作的剧本里的任何单句台词都要好。所以不，我是认真的。你太客气了。我是这么记的。我是这么记的。关于在办公室工作，以及为什么在格雷格·丹尼尔斯的悉心教导下，那是一个如此神奇的时间和工作地点，我想说的是：因为我们被允许这样做，被允许带来我们的想法。而且归根结底，并不是所有的编剧——有些编剧会说，不，我只想在剪辑室里坚持剧本里的台词。但在剪辑
but it's a very good team. But I very vividly remember rain improvising that line because with great respect, I considered it a dunk on me as the writer that he would just on the spot come up with a line that was probably better than any single line in the script that I had worked so hard on. So no, I mean it. You're very, you're very kind. That's how I remembered it. I remembered it. Here's what I want to say about working in the office and why it was such a magical time and place to work under the tutelage of Greg Daniels because because we were allowed to do that and to bring our ideas. And at the end of the day, not all the writers were some of the writers were like, no, I want to just stick to the lines in the script in the editing room. But in the editing
室里，大部分时候，尤其是格雷格和我们的首席剪辑师戴夫在里面的时候，他们只会采用最搞笑的部分，他们会觉得，听着，我才不管纸上写的是什么。我才不管原本应该是什么样的。我们只会采用最搞笑、效果最好的、被摄像机捕捉到的内容，并围绕它来制作这一集。所以这有一种非常美好的感觉，你知道的，你可以尽可能地即兴发挥。它可能最后会被剪掉。但如果你即兴发挥的内容增添了亮点并提升了效果，它很可能会被保留下来。所以每个人都觉得自己是一个有价值的贡献者。相信我，从那以后我也去过很多电视剧片场，之前也去过。但情况根本不是这样的。和格雷格一起工作把我彻底惯坏了，
room for the most part, especially of Greg and Dave, who was our chief editor, were in there, they would just take what's funniest and they would just, Lee, I don't care what's on the page. I don't care what's supposed to be there. We're just going to take what's funniest and works the best and what was captured on the camera and make the episode about that. So it was this really nice feeling like, you know, you can improvise all you wanted. It was probably going to get cut. But if you improvised and it added something and elevated it, it was probably going to make it. So everyone felt like they were a valuable contributor. And believe me, I've been on a lot of TV sets since then and before then. And that's just not the case. I got totally spoiled working with Greg
因为格雷格是真心想要我的故事。他想要我的点子。他喜欢向我抛出一连串的问题，问我当年真的当接待员时生活是什么样的。而那些小细节最后都会出现在节目中。这让我觉得，噢，原来这就是演戏。这是我的第一部电视剧。我什么都不懂。所以我后来的工作，我会带着我那些亮眼的创意、故事和传说走进编剧办公室。然后我很快意识到，绝大多数剧集运作人和编剧都会说：闭嘴。不感兴趣。请离开我的办公室。我正忙着给你写台词呢。然后我就想，啊。我得告诉你们，这算是一个有点尴尬的时刻。在《办公室》结束之后，我为TBS电视台拍了一部多机位情景喜剧叫《你的家庭还是我的家庭》（Your Family or Mine）。我以前从来没有
because Greg truly wanted my stories. He wanted my ideas. He loved to pepper me with questions about what my life was like when I was really a receptionist. And those little things would find their way into the show. And it made me feel like, oh, this is what it is. This is my first TV show. I didn't know any different. So jobs that I've had since, I will go into the writers' offices and out with my bright ideas and my stories and my lore. And I realized quickly that most show runners and writers are like, stop talking. Not interested. Please leave my office. I'm trying to write dialogue for you. And I was like, aw. I have to tell you guys this is sort of an embarrassing moment. After the office ended, I did a multicam for TBS called Your Family or Mine. And I'd never
真正那样拍过多机位情景喜剧。在布景调整的间隙，我跑去找编剧们，他们其实人挺好的。但我跑过去对他们说：伙计们，我有几个点子。他们当时反应是：不好意思。不好意思，什么？我们不听什么点子。如果我们有了想法，我们会来找你的。我们的观众都已经入场就座了。金斯利，你可不能随随便便就跑到这边来，然后说：嘿，我有个点子。这就好像，不行。BJ，作为一名在《办公室》之后继续创作更多作品并创建了自己的节目的编剧和剧集运作人，你是如何运营你的节目的？你有借鉴格雷格的方式吗？这是一个混合体吗？嗯，我在运营几个刚起步的节目方面还非常非常早期。所以我其实没有
done a multicam before, really like that. And in between setups, I ran over to the writers and they were really nice. But I ran over to them and I'm like, guys, I have a few pitches. They were like, I'm sorry. I'm sorry, what? We're not doing any pitches. We'll come to you if we have an idea. We have an audience loaded in. You don't just, Kinsey, get to come over here on the fly and be like, hey, I got a pitch. It's like, no. B.J., as a writer and showrunner who has gone on to do more things after the office and you created your own show, how do you run your shows? Have you borrowed from Greg's way? Is it a mix? Well, I'm very, I'm very early in showrunning a couple of shows that I'm just getting off the ground. So I don't actually have
太多作为剧集运作人的经验。不过，仅仅再次谈到格雷格对演员的看法——我非常从他那里汲取或者向他学习并与之产生共鸣，他，他，有很多原因让我觉得他希望我和明迪、保利·伯恩斯坦以及迈克·舒尔去演摩斯（Moes），我们可以深入探讨这一点，因为里面有很多有趣的心理学以及创造力。而且在试播集的早期，格雷格会把安吉拉和奥斯卡特别当作他知道会演得很好的人来谈论，当时他还不知道这些角色具体是什么样的，因为他信任他们作为即兴演员的能力。我认为，让一些人，你知道的，一些大使在编剧室和片场之间来回穿梭，作为编剧，会教导你信任演员的直觉，因为我知道，对于你表演的时候来说，这是挺身而出的。你是前线最后的防线。你是前线的士兵，你知道是否有子弹朝你飞来，或者你是否正开足马力，无论如何，你身体里是有感觉的。所以如果你知道有什么地方不对劲，或者，过了一会儿，你就是知道这行不通。这会显得很假。这不是你的角色。而且我认为，当你知道这一点并把它告诉编剧时，如果编剧没有这方面的经验，他们会觉得你在耍大牌。他们会觉得你只是想要一句更好的台词或者你想显得很重要。他们没有意识到你可能比他们更懂，因为
much experience as a showrunner a little. But I just to speak about Greg's view towards actors again, which I very much sort of took from him or learned from him and connected to, he, he, the, there are a lot of reasons why I think he wanted me and Mindy and Pauley, Bernstein and Mike Sher to play Moe's, which we can totally get into because there's a lot of fun psychology at play there as well as creativity. And the fact that in the early days of the pilot, Greg would talk about Angela and Oscar in particular, as people he knew would be good and he didn't know yet what the characters were exactly because he trusted them as improvisers. I think that having people, you know, some ambassadors go back and forth between the
实际上是你在演。通常你写一句台词，你知道的，我在片场和节目中的经验越多，我就越清楚这一点，我就越知道要倾听演员的意见。我想格雷格也知道这一点。这话讲得太美妙了。我知道他需要他自己的播客了，一个关于电视剧编剧或电视剧编剧的播客。嗯，我当时，我当时希望那个飞船的声音能响起来。这样你们就会纳闷：这家伙是从哪弄来这个的？不知道。你们说话的整个过程，我都只是觉得：嗯……因为我觉得这话讲得太好了。嗯。我想，我想我们非常幸运，我们的节目是一个充满创意的合作项目，而且当情况并非如此时，我们绝对能感受到这种前行的阻力。格雷格经常说，他之所以那么频繁地找我们，
writer's room and set teaches you as writers to trust the actor's instincts because I know this is a stand up to you performing it. You are the last line of defense. You are the soldier on the front line and you know if there are bullets coming at you or if you're firing on all cylinders or whatever, you know in your body. So if you know something isn't working or, or after a little while, you just know it's not going to work. You're going to feel fake. It's not going to be your character. And I think that when you know that and you tell that to writers, if the writer has no experience with it, they think you're being a diva. They think you just want a better line or you want to be important. They don't realize that you might know better than them because
是因为他真的很信任我们。这也是他试镜过程的一部分，也就是雇佣那些他觉得可以用这种方式去交流的演员。你知道我的意思吗？这就好像，说实话，并不是，并不是每个演员都有好的点子。我不知道。这无所谓。并不是每个演员在创意上都与我们在本剧中所做的事情保持一致。并不是每个演员都在寻找一句能在他们内心深处产生共鸣、非常个人化、符合角色的台词。有时他们只是想要一句他们觉得很酷的台词之类的，对吧？是的。而这可能不适合像我们这样的节目。我确实有一个构思，我试了四五次想向保罗和格雷格推销，因为保罗·利伯斯坦接手当了几季的剧集运作人。
you're actually, they're doing it. And often you write a line, you know, the more experience I had on set on the show, the more I knew that, the more I knew to listen to the actors. I think Greg knew that too. That was so beautifully said. I know he needs his own podcasting, a podcast about TV writing or TV writers. Well, I was, I was hoping that the, the spaceship sound came in. So you guys would wonder like, where is he getting this? I don't know. The whole time you were talking, I was just kind of like, huh, because I thought it was so well said. Yeah. I think, I think what we were very fortunate that our show was a creative collaboration and, and we definitely feel that moving forward when it's not the case. Greg would often say that the reason that he went to us
结果它从未实现。我当时想，噢，天哪，你们错失了人生中最大的机会，那就是——现在回想起来这挺荒谬的，但我深信它一定会很棒——那就是在早期有一些场景，里面有迈克尔、德怀特、吉姆、帕姆和劳尔等等等等。然后镜头摇向克里德，克里德看着镜头说：嘿，伙计。镜头环顾四周，仿佛在说：来吧，来吧，跟我来。然后摄像团队跟着克里德走了出去，他们上了克里德的车。在接下来的整集中，克里德向他们展示了他的生活，他带着他们参观了克里德的世界。我的意思是，他去了一个锐舞派对，他住在一个废弃的啤酒厂里，他还养了宠物浣熊。然后他去抢劫了一家酒类专卖店。他说：他就像是，来吧。整集几乎没有对话，你只是跟着克里德穿过这个疯狂迷宫。我觉得如果你拍到了第137集，你已经赢得了这样一集的资格，你可以做这样的事情，但它没有，它没有发生。我在《午夜威胁级别》中也有过类似的感受，我不知道这到底是是对还是错。我想我们从讲述框架故事中得到了很多好东西。但你知道，我当时想要的是直接把《午夜威胁级别》呈献给观众。我想当时有一种传统的、而且极有可能正确的做法，但那是一种传统的
so much was because he really trusted us. And that was part of the audition process for him, which was hiring actors that he felt he could go to in this way. You know what I mean? It's like, I mean, to be fair, like not, not every actor has great ideas. I don't know. Like it doesn't matter. Not every actor is aligned creatively with what we were doing on this show. Not every actor is looking for a line that resonates deep within them, is personal, is the character. Sometimes they just want a line they think would be cool or something, right? Yeah. And that, that might not work for a show like ours. I did have a pitch that I, I tried four or five times to pitch to Paul and Greg, because Paul Lieberstein took over for a couple of seasons there as showrunner.
很大程度上是因为他真的很信任我们。这也是他试镜过程的一部分，也就是挑选他觉得可以这样信任的演员。你知道我的意思吗？就是说，公平地说，并不是每个演员都有很好的想法。我不知道。这没关系。并非每个演员在创意上都与我们在本剧中所做的事情保持一致。并非每个演员都在寻找一句能在内心深处引起共鸣、与自己息息相关、符合角色身份的台词。有时他们只是想要一句他们觉得很酷的台词之类的，对吧？是的。而这对于我们这样的节目来说可能行不通。我确实有一个点子，我曾向保罗和格雷格推销过四五次，因为保罗·利伯斯坦接手担任了几个季度的剧集主管。
And it was, it never happened. And I just thought, oh my God, you're missing the opportunity of your lives, which is, and it's pretty preposterous when I look back on it now, but I was convinced it would have been great, which is like early on, there's just some scenes and it's Michael and Dwight and Jim and Pam and Raul, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then it pans over to Creed and Creed is like, looks to the camera and Creed goes, Hey, buddy. And the camera's like looking and it's like, come on, come on, come with me. And the camera crew follows Creed out and they get into Creed's car. And the entire episode, Creed is then showing them his life, he's taking them on a tour of the world of Creed. I mean, he goes to a rave and he's living in an
结果它从来没有被采用过。我当时就想，天哪，你们错失了人生中绝佳的机会。现在回想起来，这其实挺荒谬的，但我当时坚信它会非常棒。那就是在早期，有一些场景是迈克尔、德怀特、吉姆、帕姆和劳尔等等等等。然后镜头转向克里德，克里德看着镜头说，嘿，兄弟。然后镜头好像在看着，仿佛在说，来吧，来吧，跟我来。摄影组跟着克里德走了出去，他们上了克里德的车。在接下来的整集里，克里德向他们展示自己的生活，带他们参观克里德的世界。我的意思是，他去了一个锐舞派对，他住在一个
abandoned beer factory and he's got pet raccoons. And then he goes and he robs a liquor store. And he's like, he's just like, come on. And the whole thing is like almost dialogue free, you're just following Creed through this like insane maze. And I feel like you've earned that if you're on episode 137, you've earned an episode where you can do something like that, but it didn't, it didn't happen. I found something similar with threat level midnight where I, I don't know if it was right or wrong. And I think we got a lot of good stuff from telling the frame story. But you know, what I wanted was just drop threat level midnight on the audience. And I think there, there was a traditional and very, very likely correct, but a traditional
废弃的啤酒厂里，他还养了宠物浣熊。然后他去抢劫了一家酒类专卖店。他就好像在说，来吧。整集几乎没有对话，你只是跟着克里德穿过这个疯狂的迷宫。我觉得如果你拍到了第137集，你确实有资格拍这样一集，你可以做类似的事情，但它最终没有发生。我在拍《危情时速午夜版》时也有类似的想法，我不知道这到底是对还是错。我认为通过讲述画中画的故事，我们得到了很多精彩的内容。但你知道，我真正想要的是直接把《危情时速午夜版》呈献给观众。而且我认为，当时有一种传统且非常、非常可能是正确的观点，但那是一种传统的观点
view of you don't, we don't do one-off experiments on this show. You know, we tell the story. And there's A and a B and a C story and you've got to stick to that. Yeah, it wasn't experimental. And it did work by and large, the show. So I can't really argue. But yeah, I'm sort of experimental like you, Rain. I like that kind of thing. I feel like community did things like that. Yes, every episode. They could get away with that. Really wild one-offs. And I definitely, I'm with you, Rain. I pitched a few times that, that we would follow characters home. And I was, you know, told pretty quickly, but it's the office. It's called the office. We're not going other places.
你看，我们在这个节目里从来不做一次性的实验。你知道的，我们讲故事。这里有主线A、B和C故事，你必须坚持下去。是的，这并不是实验性的。而且总的来说，这部剧确实成功了。所以我真的没法争辩。但是，是的，我跟你有点像，雷恩，我很喜欢那种实验性的东西。我觉得《废柴联盟》就做过类似的事。是的，每一集。他们能那样做。真的非常疯狂的一对一。而且我绝对，我和你一样，雷恩，我曾好几次提议说，我们可以跟随角色回家。而我，你知道的，很快就被告知，但这是《办公室》。它叫《办公室》。我们不会去其他地方。
But in this episode, and here's Steering Us Back, we go to Dwight's beat farm. So we do, we do go home with a character. But, and is, is this, what time is this? Was this the first time? Second time we went to Dwight's farm? And was this the first time? Got to be the first time. And was it the production of Moe's? Was this the first time with Moe's? Yeah. Yes. Yes. Well, this episode was history then. Yes. So, well, let's see. Well, let me just say, as a writer who obsessed about things like this, that the audience didn't give a shit about at the end of the day, which was how would the documentarians be or not be allowed to follow certain things? You know, we would always say,
但在这集中，我们把方向扳了回来，我们去了德怀特的甜菜农场。所以我们确实和一个角色一起回了家。但是，这，这是什么时候？这是第一次吗？我们去德怀特农场是第二次吗？这是第一次吗？一定是第一次。而且那是莫斯（Moe's）的制作吗？这是莫斯第一次出现吗？是的。是的。是的。好吧，这一集当时就是历史了。是的。所以，好吧，让我们看看。好吧，让我这么说吧，作为一个对这类事情着迷的编剧，观众到头来根本不在乎，那就是纪录片制作团队会被允许或不被允许跟随某些事情到什么程度？你知道，我们总是会说，
you'd never see Jim and Pam's bedroom because they would never invite the cameras there. Are you crazy? Whereas Dwight's beat farm, the camera crew would be very interested. It's very relevant to this new employee, Ryan's journey at Thunder Mifflin. It's very relevant to this major personality at Thunder Mifflin Dwight. It's fundamental to his nature. We've heard about it a lot. He would be extremely eager to show his beat farm, especially as part of a work-related milestone for someone in his mind. So it makes total sense we go to the beat farm. This we spent forever talking about what would and wouldn't happen and what camera angles would and wouldn't be possible. And I don't think the audience cared at all. I did my research and I spent 21 minutes
你永远不会看到吉姆和帕姆的卧室，因为他们绝不会邀请摄像机去那里。你疯了吗？而德怀特的甜菜农场，摄影组会非常感兴趣。这与新员工瑞安在邓德米夫林的旅程高度相关。这与邓德米夫林这个重要的个性人物德怀特高度相关。这触及了他的本质。我们已经听过很多关于它的事了。他会非常渴望展示他的甜菜农场，特别是在他看来，这是某人与工作相关的里程碑的一部分。所以我们去甜菜农场完全合情合理。我们花了很长时间讨论会发生什么、不会发生什么，以及哪些镜头角度是可能的、哪些是不可能的。而我认为观众根本不在乎。我做了功课，昨晚我花了21分钟
and 40 seconds watching the episode last night, so in preparation for this podcast. And it was just a joy to watch. But as I watched that, I was like, oh, this is Pam's episode. It's called the initiation. And yes, the flashy part is Dwight in the barn and the car and Ryan and the eggs and whatnot. But really, it's the heart and soul of this episode is Pam being told by Jan to spy on Michael. And then the exquisitely beautiful scene with Pam and Jim at the end that is by far the longest scene. I mean, it must have been a five-page scene and had so much heart in it and subtlety. And so I'd love to hear the Pam perspective on this episode. I had forgotten about that scene when I re-watched this episode. I forgot that happened at the end.
40秒观看了这一集，以此为这档播客做准备。看这一集真是一种享受。但当我观看时，我在想，哦，这是帕姆的一集。它叫《入职培训》。是的，引人注目部分是德怀特在谷仓里、车里，还有瑞安和鸡蛋等等。但实际上，这一集的灵魂是简让帕姆去监视迈克尔。然后是帕姆和吉姆在结尾处那段精致美丽的场景，这绝对是最长的场景。我的意思是，这一定是一个五页剧本的场景，里面有如此丰富的情感和微妙之处。所以我很想听听这一集中帕姆的视角。我重看这一集时，差点把那个场景给忘了。我忘了那是发生在结尾的。
I held my breath and I was on the edge of my seat and I was like, what is happening? Don't get off the phone. Stay on the phone. Say feelings. Say you miss him. You know, I'm just remembering. It's so funny. Rain, we were talking about the experimental episode because that card was on the board for a long time, Jim and Pam's phone call. And it was going to take the whole episode. I fought so hard. I wanted it to be because it just happens at the end for a long time, right? The way we shot it. I wanted it to keep coming back to it and it's still going. And it goes the whole episode. They're on the phone the whole episode. In the DVD commentary, BJ, you mentioned that in your mind, this conversation went on for like
我屏住了呼吸，坐在座位边缘，我想，发生了什么？别挂电话。留在电话里。说出你的感受。说你想他。你知道的，我只是在回忆。太有趣了。雷恩，我们之前在谈论那个实验性的片段，因为那个方案在白板上挂了很久，也就是吉姆和帕姆的电话。而且它本该持续整整一集。我争取了那么久。我想让它成为……因为直到结尾才发生，对吧？我们拍摄的方式。我希望它能不断回到这个场景，而且它还在继续。它贯穿了整整一集。他们打了一整集的电话。在DVD评论中，BJ，你提到在你的脑海里，这段对话持续了大约
three hours. Yeah, that sounds right. I wanted it to be threaded through the episode. And then I even wonder if I wanted it to be a whole episode at one point, their phone call, which is again, in line with me and Rain's sort of experimental one off outlier episode love. But yeah, I remember that phone call. And I remember writing the line, the one line I remember them proud of is, what time zone are you in? Same time zone. Oh, it felt far. I was like, yes, of course. Beautiful line. That got me. In watching this episode, I was like, oh, this is why this show has stood the test of time. Because you have scenes that are outrageously over the top. And then all of a sudden, it's two people in love that hardly
三个小时。是的，听起来差不多。我希望它能穿插在这一集中。然后我甚至怀疑，我曾经想过让他们的电话聊天成为一整集，这再次符合我和雷恩对那种实验性的、独一无二的离群剧集的喜爱。但是，是的，我记得那通电话。我记得我写过的那句台词，我唯一引以为豪的一句台词是：你在哪个时区？同一个时区。哦，感觉好遥远。我当时想，是的，当然。美丽的台词。这击中了我。在看这一集时，我想，哦，这就是这部剧经受住时间考验的原因。因为你既有那些荒谬夸张的场景，然后突然之间，是两个相爱却几乎
know they're in love, having an almost unedited five minute conversation that it's almost like it's in real time. And you have so this moment of like, real heart underneath it that grounds that whole experience. And I always love that Greg talked about having that, you know, a show can't support more than like 10 or 15% hearts. It's got to have 80, 85% comedy in it to work. But you can't leave out that 10, 15% of reality. Or else you'll have lost the audience. Greg was good with percentages. He also had the 5% rule, which was that every character, you should try to move them forward 5%, surprise them 5%. If a character is always exactly what you expect, it gets boring and you fall into cliched ideas of what Angela would do or whatever.
不知道他们相爱的人，进行了一场几乎未经剪辑的五分钟对话，感觉就像是实时发生的。你有一种内心深处真实情感的时刻，为整个经历奠定了基调。我一直很喜欢格雷格所说的，一部剧的情感成分不能支持超过百分之十或十五。它必须包含百分之八十到八十五的喜剧才能成功。但你不能忽略那百分之十到十五的现实。否则你就会失去观众。格雷格很擅长百分比。他还有百分之五规则，也就是说对于每个角色，你应该努力让他们向前推进百分之五，让他们有百分之五的惊喜。如果一个角色总是完全符合你的预期，就会变得很无聊，你就会陷入对安吉拉会做什么之类的陈词滥调中。
And if you change it by 50% or 100%, if all of a sudden Michael has read the complete Shakespeare, it's funny, but it's you killed the character. So you always want to be like, huh, all right, I kind of see that. So yeah, that's just Greg with, if he, I didn't never heard him give that percentage, but that sounds like Greg, it sounds right. I just have a question, Rain. When Ryan comes up to the barn, you do this salute and people online think it's like, you sort of like, sort of imitating the salute from a BBC show called, it's called Red Dwarf. Is that from Red Dwarf, the BBC show from the 80s? I don't remember how that came out, but I I, my hunch is that in the script, and you can tell me Dwight does a strange salute or something
如果你改变百分之五十或百分之百，如果迈克尔突然读完了莎士比亚全集，这很有趣，但你毁了这个角色。所以你总是希望观众觉得，哈，好吧，我能理解那种感觉。所以，是的，这就是格雷格的风格，如果他……我从来没听过他给出那个百分比，但听起来很像格雷格，听起来很对。我只有一个问题，雷恩。当瑞安走到谷仓时，你做了一个敬礼，网民们认为这有点像……有点在模仿一个名叫《红矮星》的BBC节目的敬礼。那是来自80年代的BBC节目《红矮星》吗？我不记得这是怎么来的了，但我……我的直觉是，在剧本里，你可以告诉我，德怀特做了一个奇怪的敬礼还是别的什么
like that. So I had to kind of come up with what that was. Maybe that's not in the script. I don't know, you can research that, but I don't know what that was, but I like that it's kind of like World War one Germany, kind of like the Kaiser, like that's how you would salute the Kaiser. Can I point out, I'm realizing this is not our first first writer-actor collaboration where I write a stage direction for Dwight, that he makes iconic, which is, I remember in the fire, in the fire, I wrote the fire truck arrives and Dwight pumps his fist. And I think Greg was like, huh? And I was like, no, he's like a little boy. He just sees a fire truck and he's like, yeah. And you did it. It's great. Now it's like a
之类的。所以我必须想出那是什么。也许那不在剧本里。我不知道，你可以去查证一下，但我不知道那是什么，但我喜欢它有点像一战时的德国，有点像德皇，就像你会那样向德皇敬礼一样。我能指出吗？我意识到这不是我们第一次进行编剧兼演员的合作，我为德怀特写了一个舞台动作，他把它变成了一个标志性的动作，也就是我记得在《火灾》那一集里，消防车到达时，德怀特挥舞着拳头。我想格雷格当时问，哈？而我说，不，他就像一个小男孩。他只是看到了一辆消防车，然后就想，耶。而你做到了。太棒了。现在这就像一个
jiff or something. It's like a meme. It's just, it's exactly what I dreamed of. I think on that, you know, we had like eight takes or something. So at first it was like standard fist pump. And then it got bigger and bigger until finally at the end it's like, yeah. Oh my God, BJ is so tickled. I'm just laughing at how much Dwight loved. It's a toaster oven, like with a little bit of smoke. And he sees a fire truck and he's like, yes. This is such an excessive solution. Although I suppose that's what happens when the alarm goes off. They just come, but it's just like, he would think this is appropriate as opposed to annoying. All right, all right. It would put Dwight at ranks in like his top 10 best days ever.
GIF动图什么的。这就像一个表情包。这正是我梦寐以求的。我想在那场戏里，我们拍了大约八条左右。所以一开始就像标准的挥拳。然后动作越来越大，直到最后变成，耶。哦天哪，BJ被逗乐了。我只是在笑德怀特有多喜欢这个。那是一个烤面包机，带有一点烟雾。他看到了一辆消防车，然后就想，太棒了。这真是个过度的反应。虽然我想当警报响起时就会这样。他们只是来了，但就像，他会认为这是恰当的而不是烦人的。好吧，好吧。这会让德怀特排在他有生以来前十个最佳日子的前列。
Like if he was making a journal like Dear Diary, best days ever. Number four, fire truck showed up to Dunder Mifflin. Another thing I improvised in this episode was in the barn, going back to the barn now, the thing of like most world animals. Yes, I was going to ask you that, right? Yeah. I love that line so much. But we were laughing, BJ and I, about it on the set and just kind of like, we didn't quite know how to, I don't know that it ultimately landed as a joke, but the idea that there should have been, it should have been filled with animals, but now it was empty of animals. So what did Moe's do with all the animals? Where did he put them? He probably brought them and put them in the house. And that might have been a nice cut
就像如果他在写日记，比如“亲爱的日记，有生以来最好的一天。第四名，消防车开到了邓德米夫林”。我在这一集中即兴创作的另一件事是在谷仓里，现在回到谷仓，关于大多数世界动物的事。是的，我正要问你呢，雷恩？是的。我太喜欢那句台词了。但我和BJ在片场时对此大笑，而且有点像……我们不太清楚怎么处理，我不知道它最终有没有达到笑点的效果，但这个想法本应该是，谷仓里应该充满动物，但现在里面没有动物了。那么莫斯把所有的动物都弄哪去了？他把它们放在哪了？他可能把它们带进屋里了。这可能是一个很好的转场镜头
away that Moe's, where's all the animals? And then just cut away to Dwight's actual house with a filled with cows and sheep and pigs and chickens and whatnot. Speaking of this scene, can I play an audio clip from the scene? I asked Sam to pull this audio clip from when Dwight is rapid fire questioning Ryan. Can you play that clip, Sam? What is the greatest danger facing Dunder Mifflin? Outsourcing and consolidation of competition. Wrong. Flash floods. What is the true cause of Robert Mifflin's suicide? Depression. Wrong. He hated himself. What is the Dharma initiative? Final question, young Ryan Howard. What is Michael Scott's greatest fear? Loneliness. Maybe women. Wrong. He's not afraid of anything. Also, I would have accepted snakes.
，莫斯，所有的动物都在哪？然后直接转场到德怀特的真正的房子里，里面挤满了牛、羊、猪、鸡等等。说到这个场景，我能播放一段该场景的音频剪辑吗？我让萨姆提取了这段音频剪辑，当时德怀特正在连珠炮般地盘问瑞安。你能播放那个剪辑吗，萨姆？邓德米夫林面临的最大危险是什么？外包和竞争对手的整合。错。山洪暴发。罗伯特·米夫林的真正死因是什么？抑郁症。错。他讨厌自己。达摩计划是什么？最后一个问题，年轻的瑞安·霍华德。迈克尔·斯科特最大的恐惧是什么？孤独。也许是女人。错。他什么都不怕。另外，我本来也接受蛇这个答案。
I believe Justin Spitzer wrote that pitch. Justin Spitzer in the writer's room, you know, you send writers off sometimes to just like, all right, you write a bunch of questions, you and you write this scene. And I remember Justin coming back with some really good stuff. And I think he wrote Loneliness, which I loved. But then you said, or maybe fear of women. Yeah. Who put maybe women? Oh. Loneliness was your first take on Michael's greatest fear. And then you say, or maybe women. And then Dwight is like false, but I would accept snakes. He's not afraid of anything, but I would have accepted snakes. Right. What a loyalist. But guys, this is the scene that introduces Moe's. We were talking about Moe's and Mike's sure.
我相信贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）写了那个段子。贾斯汀·斯皮策在编剧室里，你知道的，你们有时会打发编剧去……好吧，你写一堆问题，你和你们来写这场戏。我记得贾斯汀带回了一些真的很棒的东西。我想他写了“孤独”，我很喜欢。但随后你说，或者也许是害怕女人。是谁加了“也许是女人”？哦。孤独是你对迈克尔最大恐惧的第一反应。然后你说，或者也许是女人。然后德怀特说“错误，但我会接受蛇”。他什么都不怕，但我会接受蛇。对。真是个死忠粉。但是伙计们，这是介绍莫斯的场景。我们刚才在谈论莫斯和迈克·舒尔。
How did that come about? Everyone wants to know. Mike did an interview where he said that's his real beard and it took him three months to grow. Wait, all of that underneath? And that is hilarious. That was his hair? Yeah, that's his real hair. Oh my God. Yes. Like, I thought I had it hard having to wear cheesy blonde highlights for six months. But Moe's Mike had to wear a neck beard. And again, it's only a neck beard. He's like a classy dude. He's married. He's a TV producer. People know him. He has social engagement. So he's walking around with his neck beard, the thick neck beard for months and months and months. And this nothing made Greg Daniels happier or more amused than what Mike had to go through as sort of supervising producer of
那是怎么来的？每个人都想知道。迈克做过一次采访，他说那是他真正的胡子，花了他三个月的时间才留出来。等等，下面所有的都是？太搞笑了。那是他的头发？是的，那是他真正的头发。哦天哪。是的。就像，我还以为我不得不连续六个月戴着俗气的金色挑染假发很不容易呢。但莫斯·迈克不得不留着颈须。而且再次强调，这只是颈须。他是个体面的家伙。他结婚了。他是一个电视制作人。人们认识他。他有社交活动。所以他顶着颈须，那厚厚的颈须走来走去，持续了几个月又几个月。没有什么比迈克作为……的监事制片人所经历的一切更让格雷格·丹尼尔斯感到高兴或觉得好笑了
the office. And yet he also had to wear this neck beard. He never asked to act. And the funniest part of it is that Mike kept asking, don't you think we could just use a fake beard? And Greg said, no, absolutely not. People will tell the difference. And then I don't know what the reason was, but maybe it was like we suddenly came back from, you know, a long hiatus and a rewrite had to throw Moe's in a scene. He didn't have the beard. And we just threw a $5 fake beard on. It was indistinguishable. Totally fine. Now, how did they decide Mike sure was going to play his Amish farmer cousin? Yeah, I think it was, I'm 60% confident. It was a room bit. I think Mike did the voice in sort of never thinking it would lead to anything.
办公室。然而他还必须留着这个颈须。他从来没有要求过演戏。最搞笑的部分是迈克一直问，你不觉得我们随便用个假胡子就行了吗？格雷格说，不，绝对不行。人们能看出区别的。然后我不知道原因是什么，也许是因为我们突然从，你知道的，漫长的停工期回来，重写剧本不得不把莫斯塞进一个场景里。他没有胡子。我们只好随便贴上了一个5美元的假胡子。根本看不出来区别。完全没问题。现在，他们是怎么决定让迈克·舒尔去扮演他那个阿米什农夫表弟的？是的，我想，我有百分之六十的把握。那是编剧室的一个段子。我想迈克用了那种声音，当时根本没想过这会有什么后续发展。
There's a lot of room bits where you're just joking around for hours, cracking each other up as a way of warming up. And maybe it leads to something who knows just goofing off. And I think as a room bit, he did that voice. And maybe that's what cracked Greg up and made him think. So then we took the picture. But I think the idea was always someday we'll see Moe's nudge, nudge. But like, we didn't even know if we'd be picked up, you know, but I do think it was, I do think it was assumed that he would play Moe's if it ever happened. We have a fan question from Quinn Moldenhauer. Finally. Yes, he would like to know what would have happened if Ryan had actually gotten in the coffin? What were you going to do?
编剧室里有很多段子，你们只是开玩笑好几个小时，互相逗笑作为热身。也许它会有所发展，谁知道呢，只是瞎胡闹。我想作为一个编剧室的段子，他模仿了那个声音。也许这就是逗乐格雷格并让他产生想法的原因。所以后来我们拍了照片。但我想这个想法一直是“总有一天我们会看到莫斯，懂的都懂”。但是，就像，我们甚至不知道我们是否会被续订，你知道的，但我确实认为，我确实认为大家默认如果这事真的发生了，他就会扮演莫斯。我们有一个来自奎因·莫尔登豪尔（Quinn Moldenhauer）的粉丝问题。终于来了。是的，他想知道如果瑞安真的进了棺材会发生什么？你们打算怎么做？
Were you going to bury him next to your grandfather? What was going to happen? Yeah, he was going to put a padlock. He's going to put a padlock on the coffin. They were going to wheel it via donkey cart out through the shrewd cemetery. And they were going to bury him. And they're going to, and he's going to, Moe's was going to dress up like a chaplain and do a eulogy so that Ryan had a taste of death and then the sweetness of life. And then they would bury him, Dwight would rescue him and bring the coffin up, throw the dirt off the coffin, undo the padlock, open it up. Ryan would be like, what the fuck, Dwight? And Dwight would be like, I rescued you, Ryan. I rescued you. Welcome. You're alive. You made it. You're alive.
你们要把他埋在你祖父旁边吗？到底会发生什么？是的，他要在棺材上挂一把挂锁。他们要用驴车把它运过施鲁德家族的墓地。然后他们要埋了他。他们要……莫斯要打扮成牧师做悼词，这样瑞安就能体验到死亡的滋味，然后再体验生活的美好。然后他们会把他埋了，德怀特会救他出来，把棺材抬上来，把棺材上的土扔掉，解开挂锁，打开它。瑞安会说，搞什么鬼，德怀特？然后德怀特会说，我救了你，瑞安。我救了你。欢迎。你还活着。你成功了。你还活着。
You're reborn. You're reborn. You're reborn as a Dunder Mifflin. And I saved you. And then that this would be a profound experience. That sounds right. I like that. Quinn will be very happy to hear. On that note, I'm going to move us along to Axelrod Limited. We find out that they didn't like Ryan. They didn't make the sale. Rain, you have that great line where you're like, I mean, they didn't need to say it to your face. It's a great line. It's really great. But so then you guys end up egging the building. We had a fan question from Chandra who wants to know, did you throw real eggs at the building? Do you guys remember? Yeah. So the Axelrod sign that's hanging up on the side of the building was a fabrication from our
你重生了。你重生了。作为邓德米夫林员工重生了。我救了你。然后这将是一次深刻的体验。听起来很对。我喜欢这样。奎因听到这个会很高兴的。顺便说一句，我要把话题转到阿克斯罗德有限公司（Axelrod Limited）。我们发现他们不喜欢瑞安。他们没有做成那笔生意。雷恩，你有那句很棒的台词，你说，我的意思是，他们不需要当面说出来。这是一句很棒的台词。真的很棒。但后来你们俩去朝大楼扔鸡蛋了。我们有一个来自钱德拉（Chandra）的粉丝问题，她想知道，你们真的向大楼扔鸡蛋了吗？你们还记得吗？是的。所以挂在大楼侧面的阿克斯罗德招牌是我们
art department. And they hung it up there. And that was our target. And we had worked out with the building itself. We had a pressure hose right there. And as soon as we rapidly took that sign down, pressure washed it, cleaned up all the egg everywhere. That was kind of part of the contract of the location. Yeah. I remember that. Yeah. Kent told me that that building was in the parking lot where your trailers were. So when you were shooting in the beat field, this is where they had the craft services. And this is where they had your trailers. And then there was this building. And he said he went in and asked the owner and property manager if they could do this scene. And he was like, no, I just want you to know this includes egging your building.
艺术部门制作的道具。他们把它挂在那里。那是我们的目标。我们已经和建筑管理方协商好了。那里有一根高压水管，当我们迅速把那个招牌取下来、用高压水枪冲洗、清理掉各处的鸡蛋液后。那是场地合同的一部分。是的。我记得那个。是的，肯特告诉我那栋楼就在你们房车停放的停车场里。所以当你们在甜菜田拍摄时，他们就是在那里提供后勤餐饮服务的。这也是你们房车停放的地方。然后旁边就是这栋楼。他说他进去问了业主和物业经理是否可以拍摄这场戏，他说，不，我只是想让你们知道这包括向你们的大楼扔鸡蛋。
And he said at this point, the office was so popular that the guy was like, that's fantastic. Yeah. Definitely. Definitely. You can egg my building. Like he was super on board. It didn't matter. Throw as many eggs at it as you want. Ryan and Dwight go on to have drinks at a bar. They do car bombs together. Dwight calls the temp. You actually call him Ryan. You guys have come together. We've had quite a day. People want to know how many takes did it take for you guys to do all those beers? How many beers did you have? People love asking that question. Jenna, they ask all the time about the cheese puffs. How many takes? How many takes of food? It's just a fascinating thing behind the scenes for people. I don't remember. I mean, I was watching
他说当时《办公室》太火了，以至于那家伙的反应是，太棒了。是的。绝对可以。绝对可以。你们可以向我的建筑扔鸡蛋。就像他超级支持一样。无所谓。想扔多少鸡蛋就扔多少。瑞安和德怀特接着去酒吧喝酒。他们一起喝了炸弹酒。德怀特管这个临时工叫……你其实叫他瑞安。你们俩走到了一起。我们度过了相当精彩的一天。人们想知道你们为了拍完所有那些啤酒拍了多少条？你们到底喝了多少啤酒？人们喜欢问这个问题。珍娜，他们总是问关于起司球的事。拍了多少条？拍了多少条食物的镜头？对人们来说，这只是幕后一个迷人的事。我不记得了。我的意思是，我在看
that scene and I thought how many times did BJ have to chug an entire beer? A fake beer. It wouldn't have been beer. Yeah, it would have been a fake beer. Near beer. But it's a lot of liquid. Probably two or three. But I probably got it in the second take and moved on. Yeah, I don't remember. It was one set up. Yeah. There you have it, guys. Thank you so much for doing this podcast with us today. It was so wonderful to see you again. This was a lot of fun. Thanks. Thank you. It's so nice to see your faces here on this Zoom. It's delightful. I miss you all. And I had such warm, fuzzy feelings. This was such a pleasure and a joy. I don't buy it. Oh, come on. So cynical. Bye. Bye, office ladies.
那个场景时，我在想BJ不得不一口气喝下一整瓶啤酒要拍多少次？假啤酒。那不可能是啤酒。是的，那会是假啤酒。无醇啤酒。但这有很多液体。可能是两三次吧。但我大概在第二条就通过了，然后继续。是的，我不记得了。这是一个镜头搞定的。是的。好了，各位。非常感谢今天能和我们一起做这个播客。再次见到你们真是太棒了。这真的很有趣。谢谢。谢谢。在Zoom上看到你们的面孔真是太好了。太令人高兴了。我很想念你们。我心里有种温暖而模糊的感觉。这真是一次愉快和快乐的体验。我才不信呢。哦，拜拜。太愤世嫉俗了。拜拜。拜拜，办公室女士们。
All right, guys. That was so great. Angela, how much fun was it to see them and hear from them? I mean, I loved hearing BJ's insights into the writer's room. That was, I'm a nerd for that, though. I love any writer's room info. I could have listened to BJ talk for, like, on and on and on because I thought it was so fascinating just to hear the process. And I think you and I share that. I love hearing the process of it all. So, BJ, you have to come back. And Rain, you were delightful too, Rain. Yes, that was such a treat to have them both. Well, listen, before we wrap up this episode, I do want to add two more things, Angela. One is from Randall Einhorn. When I was talking to him,
好了，伙计们。太棒了。安吉拉，见到他们并听到他们的声音有多开心？我的意思是，我很喜欢听BJ对编剧室的见解。那是……不过我对此是个书呆子。我喜欢任何关于编剧室的信息。我可以一直听BJ滔滔不绝地讲下去，因为我觉得听到创作过程本身就太迷人了。我想你和我都有同感。我喜欢听这一切的创作过程。所以，BJ，你必须再来。雷恩，你也很讨人喜欢，雷恩。是的，能同时邀请到他们两个真是太荣幸了。好了，听着，在我们结束这一集之前，安吉拉，我确实想补充两件事。一件是关于兰德尔·艾恩霍恩（Randall Einhorn）的。当我和他交谈时，
he put this thought in my head and I just loved it. He said that for him, the theme of this episode that he really wanted to highlight as a director was this idea of making connections. He said, Ryan and Dwight make a connection. Even after the craziness of the day, they connect and Ryan really learned something. Stanley and Michael make a connection through the pretzels and, of course, Jim and Pam. He just said that that theme of making connections is an overriding one for him with the office and it's something he loves. But he thought it was particularly highlighted in this episode. And I just thought that was a really, a really cool observation. Yeah, I think that's really beautiful. I find that Randall points out these themes to us all the
他把这个想法放进了我的脑海，我真的很喜欢。他说对他来说，作为导演，他真正想强调的这一集的主题是“建立联系”这个概念。他说，瑞安和德怀特建立了联系。即使在经历了一天的疯狂之后，他们依然建立了联系，瑞安真正学到了东西。斯坦利和迈克尔通过软 pretzels（椒盐卷饼）建立了联系，当然还有吉姆和帕姆。他只是说，“建立联系”这个主题对他来说是《办公室》中最主要的主题，也是他热爱的主题。但他认为这一集尤其突出了这一点。我只是觉得这是一个非常、非常酷的观察。是的，我觉得这真的很美。我发现兰德尔总是向我们指出这些主题，
time, whether it's about camera placement or whether you could see Pam's face after the kiss. Like Randall is really great about hitting these deeper layers of the show and what they're talking about in each episode. And then finally, this was some fan mail that we got from Amanda Bistek. She said, guys, Google Shroot Farms Trip Advisor. You will not be disappointed. And I did, Angela. There is a Trip Advisor page for Shroot Farms and there are hundreds of comments of people who claim to have stayed there. It's a fake page, but the comments are really amazing if you're an office fan because they have all these details as if they had stayed there. Oh my gosh. I wonder if people go on it and think it's an actual thing.
无论是关于镜头机位，还是关于你是否能看到帕姆亲吻后的面部表情。兰德尔真的很擅长触及这部剧更深层的内涵以及他们在每一集中讨论的内容。最后，这是我们收到的一封来自阿曼达·比斯特克（Amanda Bistek）的粉丝邮件。她说，伙计们，去谷歌搜索“施鲁德农场猫途鹰（TripAdvisor）”。你们不会失望的。我照做了，安吉拉。猫途鹰上真的有一个施鲁德农场的页面，有几百条评论，都是自称在那里住过的人写的。这是一个假页面，但如果你是《办公室》的粉丝，这些评论真的很神奇，因为它们有所有那些细节，就像他们真的在那里住过一样。哦天哪。我在想人们是不是会上去看然后以为那是真事。
I don't know. That is so funny. I love that. I'm gonna have to check that out, Amanda. Thanks for Yeah, you have to check it out. So guys, there it is. That's initiation. And we will be back next week with Diwali Diwali and another special guest. Yes, we have someone really special stopping by next week. You guys are going to be so excited. I'm so excited. So we'll see you next week and thanks so much, BJ and Rain. Yeah, guys, if you want to hear more of Rain's voice, you can listen to him discussing life's big questions on his podcast Metaphysical Milk Shake, which can be found on the Luminary app. We love you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf,
我不知道。太搞笑了。我太喜欢了。我得去查查看，阿曼达。谢谢你……是的，你得去看看。好了，各位，这就是《入职培训》。我们下周将带着《排灯节》（Diwali）和另一个特邀嘉宾回归。是的，我们下周会迎来一位非常特别的嘉宾。你们一定会超级兴奋的。我太兴奋了。所以我们下周见，非常感谢BJ和雷恩。是的，伙计们，如果你想听到更多雷恩的声音，你可以在他的播客《形而上学奶昔》（Metaphysical Milk Shake）中收听他对人生重大问题的探讨，该播客可以在Luminary应用程序上找到。我们爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）执行制片。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的录音师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubicoe）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡胶树》（Rubber Tree）。有关《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用代码 OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。